foreign
yeah good okay let's go good morning
everybody
um we have about 20 minutes here which
we're going to be using just for
imparting some information to committee
members uh then we will act on the first
bill that we'll be hearing this session
at uh 10 o'clock
so on the ride down today I had a pretty
lengthy conversation with Caitlyn Davis
over at doe regarding our uh
presentation we're going to be given on
January the 17th that's going to be at
Granite State College and we'll get
directions for you if you don't know
where that is it's just on the other
side of town here not more than a 10
minute drive from here uh so uh but they
have a room over there a conference room
which has all the bells and whistles and
the technology to facilitate the
presentation that she's going to be
presenting and other directors at the
department so we'll have a lot of
opportunity to learn about these
programs so I ask that everybody try to
make an effort to get there this is
going to be an important aspect of what
we're doing
uh it's um what they have the capability
of streaming too we're going to decide
today whether they have to do that we
have a number of times when the
education committee has taken field
trips and we've gone to various schools
whether it be down in the southern part
of the state up in the northern part of
the state or going to some small charter
schools which don't have streaming
capability
when we do these types of activities
we're not taking any action we never
take action like that at all on a bill
or we just go to learn and observe and
to see the programs that are in effect
so there are going to be times when it's
not streamed and it just can't be
streamed so I want to find out whether
we have to do it over there as well they
have the capability so I have no
problems in doing it I think it'd be
great for the public to see it as well
even those that are home that couldn't
make it here for some reason so that's
the 17th
last night I also went through and
reviewed the bills that are already on
the web that been get taken from LSR to
Bill fashion and we have now 40 Bells
and of those bills there's
13 to 15 of them that have FNS from the
financial notes
that means there are early bills
and they're going to be dealt with we
know we have probably 40 bills there we
have another 60 bills hitting us and of
that there's going to be more of them
early bills have to be out of this
committee by February the 16th we're
looking at about one month
that me and these early bills oftentimes
are bills which we the hearing process
is longer than it is for some of the
other bills seeing we're also discussing
the implications that associated with
that Financial note and in terms of
policy decisions that have to be made
staffing issues all that so they take a
little bit longer to schedule
so I'm looking now at when we're going
to start scheduling this we've got to
start hopping on our early bills
immediately so next week I meet with uh
uh Lindsay our administrative assistant
and Jen later on this this morning
sometime and try to get the schedule
built our schedules have to be submitted
for the calendar by noon or 12 30 today
on Wednesdays when we have to have that
all done unfortunately we're just
receiving these bills
um like last night and the speaker is
doing more today so uh we'll do the best
we can but I believe we're going to have
to have meetings next week on the 18th
and the 19th that is the Wednesday and
the Thursday following our Tuesday
presentation over at Granite State so
Mark in your calendars those those dates
that would be the 18th and the 19th
those are all going to be primarily
bills with FN numbers on our FN on the
back of those house bills so we're going
to be dealing with those early bills
so there's a potential to on some of
them to do maybe six a day uh counting
on well those bills sometimes take 30 to
40 to you know over 60 Minutes depending
upon the nature and the complications
and the issues associated with the bill
so and I don't want to have to rush
through some of this I want to be able
to do it carefully and so it'd be
probably maybe six like a day maybe
seven or maybe we can work in a non FN
Bill and polish that off uh during the
time when we schedule hearings we
schedule specific times the bills will
be heard so the public knows when
they're going to be excuse me when
they're going to be heard
so if we finish a bill early let's say
in 20 or 30 minutes we schedule 45
minutes for it it's just basically a
break for us and we can't schedule
anything else in there at that time and
we can't and we're not going to do this
year do any exacting of anything in the
past we had a little line underneath of
the day of the bills uh May exact bills
that have been previously heard so we
could pump anything in there and maybe
get it done this year the only way we
will ever do that if we have unanimous
consent if we have both parties agreeing
and we can get that out of the way get
over it to Paul Smith and get it heard
in the floor and move it on to the
second committee or to the Senate
so that's where we are with those those
bills on the 20th that's Friday
um I do have a trustee meeting on the
19th and the 20th of next week I'm going
to skip the 19th meeting and be there
down in Durham on the 20th so
um that takes care of that week the
following week I I think you guarantee
having three days
every week that we're going to be just
guarantee in three days and we'll try to
hit those middle three days Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Mondays I said try
not to touch so if you're scheduling
appointments there or Fridays go ahead
and do the same thing I know that there
are some even today that have doctor's
appointments and you just got to do that
you know to get into Hitchcock it takes
a month to just try to get the call
received by them and then another month
to get it scheduled and another month to
go down to the meeting of that
consultation where it's been rescheduled
so if you can get a meeting with a doc
get it and take it so don't let this
hold you back we won't be exacting any
of these bills for a while we won't be
executing them when we do exec the bills
you'll see them in the calendar they've
got to be noticed in the calendar and
all we do is put for example we start at
nine o'clock and we list the bills for
executing we don't list specific times
for when we exec so we we can jump
around you know and just take up any
Bill we want during that day and we
oftentimes will do that we'll say well
we have 20 minutes left where's the bill
I oftentimes meet with represent a mile
or represent luno and I'll say okay
which ones can you guys agree to and not
agree to and where are we and we can
just polish It Off
so so that's where the way that works
are there any questions now regarding
where we are and we have about 10
minutes here before we yeah represent
cascadden
thank you Mr chair who do we notify if
we must be absent you should notify your
ranking uh you would represent ranking
member Miler or if you can't even
represent luno okay um they will notify
uh we have to notify your leadership uh
the minority leadership and and it has
to be notified in in the majority
leadership 24 hours in advance so it we
so if you're knowing you're going to be
out if you have a now if you're going to
be up that's for exact sessions on the
hearing side we can get I can conduct a
hearing here or we can conduct a hearing
with one person present a hearing is a
different Beast than executive sessions
executive sessions you need to have a
quorum but on hearing there are days
that it may be snowing really hard down
the southern part of the State Northern
Star Park that's the way it's been
lately doesn't have as much snow unless
you're right up in the ski country and
we can make it down and we we can have
that hearing and so that's what we'll
try to do if the the shop is open here
if the capital is open
I'm inclined to go ahead with hearings I
was an administrator up in Alaska for 25
years
and we never never called off schools
because of snow or ice never they were
not caught the only time they were
called off once when the volcano went
off and we had Ash in the air and you
couldn't drive anything for fear of you
know losing your engine
so we will go ahead I always say yes you
know now if you can't come to a hearing
that's okay because that's you know I
don't want you getting yourself in an
unsafe situation or getting hurt coming
down or or if something doesn't start
too cold Etc
stay home that's fine because on a
hearing we are not making any decisions
at all we're just listening because I
was watching here first you can watch it
on YouTube but I haven't heard anything
in the past the deals were made with
local hotels to get a really cheap rate
if people had to stay over and I haven't
heard anything I'm just thinking of
people like
um rep cascadden who it takes two and a
half hours to get here and I remember at
the time the rate at the hotels was just
about equal to the mileage so it
sometimes makes sense to to stay over
but I have you heard anything there is
less alcohol
yeah um there's several different and I
don't know if new people knew about it
yeah okay right oh okay yeah we can get
that list yeah it's it's worth looking
at that list too I know that oftentimes
I couldn't get back up to Haverhill it's
about an hour and a half drive one way
and I stay at the Hampton Inn for 40
bucks a night
and that's just right over in boat
so the check them all out there there
are some good deals I know that's what
uh speaker Chandler when he came down
from down from uh uh up north up in uh
near Bartlett up in Grafton notched and
all that
he used to stay down here often at the
Holiday Inn or one of his favorite
places and they got to know him and they
gave him the same room all the time so
so it take advantage of that
unfortunately you got to pay for it too
you get a little travel but Rick yes
thanks thanks
um just to uh to karine's question a
little bit too and I think to the point
you made earlier that unlike last
session where uh where bills could be
exact at the um at the call the chair
following uh following a hearing uh day
uh that's not going to happen
um uh unless unless as Rick said
everybody's in agreement so we're really
talking about and not all but but
consent calendar type type bills uh
where there's widespread agreement
across the community so if Korean if um
or anybody can't make it to a hearing
because of weather because of you know
your your or you're under the weather or
something like that
um you don't feel like you need to get a
um get a sub for that because nothing's
going to happen
in your in your absence that wasn't the
case last um last session and we had the
same number of bills last session so you
know there were times where things had
to move through all that being said Rick
you've you've uh you mentioned that um
that uh uh February 16th is um is a is a
due out so so
um and I'm not looking at my calendar so
I don't know what that day is that a
Thursday yeah so so it's really the 15th
if they're if they're going to be in the
calendar for the following week
um so so and and I suspect if if you
know so that we're not executing a ton
of bills on one day and having a ton of
bills Hit the Floor all at the same time
um you may be in you're probably looking
at a few exact days prior to oh yes and
that that is so representative luno and
and uh I can recall
a number of times whether a reception
guile here or represented by Balboni
that was running the at that time or or
Mel or or myself that remember we also
have to have the committee reports
written and we have been coming right
down to the wire where they have to be
submitted out by 12 o'clock on a given
day and and we're acting on it at 11 30
and and so 12 you know so we have to
have those you know when we get down
like that that's where I have to start
working very closely with representative
Miler and representative luno and
representative cordelli here to make
sure that we have all that in place so
that because it's going to have to go to
Lindsay Lindsay has to look it over
let's go upstairs so Jennifer 4 they
look at that for other issues upstairs
all our reports then it comes down and
goes back over to Paul Smith and then to
the speaker's office and all this has to
transpire so they can get this in the
calendar they later on in that same week
so it it's it's uh it's real crunch time
and and people are pretty harried at
about that time so running around
everywhere so so Rick
so Rick as as um as you're you're sort
of putting together our our work path
um leading up to this February 16th and
then leading up to um to you know
crossover day but particularly the on
the first stage of this meeting February
16th if you can let us know what your
what your thoughts are for the two or
three exact days
um so that we can at least you know I
can tell you right now for example when
we're going to have the hearings coming
up here next week we're going to be
taking those those FN bills you can look
at the list you can see while all the
EFA bills are going to be there uh
there's some bills dealing with
breakfast and meal programs gonna be
there there's some rewriting adequacy
formula that's going to be there so you
pretty much tell which bills you're
going to have to handle there but the
exact sessions then we're going to try
to
take care of some of these bills as
quickly as we can or at least a week or
two before they have to be out if it's
possible seeing that we oftentimes get
an exact session and we do find times
when we want to have an amendment
and so we have to have time to write the
amendment and
it's really contrary to my position
where I want to send the bill to the
house floor where I know it's not right
or the best that we can do if we have to
have floor amendments in this in the in
the house that's not my my thing so
let's try take care of it here if we're
not ready to send it out then we've got
to work on it that's our job
um but I and I do not want to send a
bill over to the Senate say well
Senate's going to fix it
they usually don't fix it and they make
it worse and so that's that it there may
be our neighbors but sometimes they're
not our friends so
um so we got to you know I I've said
that publicly even at the well in the
house you know so I I'm wrong I'm always
really cautious so let's try to get our
work done here and so we're closing in
here in three minutes any other you know
questions so just to comment on that
Rick so there's there's basically five
weeks between now and when we need to
have those those early bills uh leaving
our committee so um so uh you know as
soon as you can sort of get us what what
your thoughts are on maybe an exec
during the final not next week but the
final week of January
yeah we want we we want to get them out
on the house floor you know as fast as
we can that's the first and second week
of February yeah right something like
that so and there may be some of these
bills too we're dealing with that are
going to go to more than two committees
we could have something going in the
criminal justice we could go on the
Health and Human Services there are
possibilities there and to finance
so so and then a fun fact that I learned
from from Jen uh a few years ago was
when you take a look at the the um you
look at all the bills that have come to
education you click on Bill status
you'll see the date that it has to leave
the committee and that that that that
really is the determination of whether
it's an early bill because some bills
with with fiscal notes are not early
bills a few we we used to get a packet
from the clerk's office on on the early
bills and it was just in a folder and it
had a Big E on it and all that we don't
get that anymore
and all we do is we get this long list
that you can pull up on the web as well
and you look at status and all these FN
bills there's nothing there there's no
dates at this point in time no dates and
so they're on the system
they're in the system they may be in the
system but yeah you have to click on
status on that okay and that's right and
you got to go to it to get it but in in
the case of this one I'm just assuming
that all these FN bills are going to
have to get out of here quickly
and that's probably a good assumption so
what we're going to do right now we're
right at 10 o'clock
and so let's you know get on to our
hearings here the first hearing if if
you have your calendars you can see the
order in which we take these off the
first one is going to be HB 71
and HP 71 is repealing a Department of
Education report on Charter Public
School funding
so do we have a representative here do
we have any pink cards okay
prep ceremony welcome
now for all those that are first time we
should see what representative Mooney's
doing right now she's handing in that
pink card which also States her name
where she's from what she's doing the
time that's necessary and you know I
hope she put a reasonable time down
there three minutes wonderful
about three days okay so once again
represent money is here today and she's
speaking to this bill dealing with
repealing the Department of Education
report on Charter Public School funding
Welcome to our committee thank you Mr
chairman and good morning to members of
the committee by means of introduction I
am representative Maureen Mooney from
the town of Merrimack Hillsborough
County District 12. I'm the prime
sponsor of House Bill 71 which you'll
hear this morning
now this bill should be relatively
simple
it repeals it repeals RSA 194 hyphen B
colon 11. Roman 1 Section lowercase e
from the charter school funding chapter
of the law which reads as follows it's
very brief but I'm going to read to you
the section in the law that my bill
wishes to delete repeal as follows quote
section e
the commissioner of the Department of
Education shall submit a report to the
fiscal Committee of the general court
for each payment made in a fiscal year
by the state to a chartered public
school pursuant to paragraph C
for each chartered Public School the
report shall contain the name and
address of the school the amount of the
payment and the number of students
currently enrolled at the school
each report shall be submitted no later
than 30 days after the payment date
specified in subparagraph C
close quote
the reason for this deletion is due to a
law change in 2016
causing the reporting requirement to now
be moot
I'm going to defer questions about that
2016 rule change to those that will
speak after me as they were here at that
time with that I'm going to close my
testimony thank you Mr chairman thank
you very much representative are there
any questions from are you willing to
take any questions as best I can yes
okay
um are there any questions from the
committee
not seeing any yes representative Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Mooney
um
I'm just wondering what kind of
reporting there is on the charter school
payments if this bill is repealed
excellent question thank you
representative for that I'm going to
defer that to just in the messengers of
time uh to the doe that will be
testifying after me
I think uh just in the interest of time
that would be a more concise accurate
answer but thank you
okay thank you for further questions
thank you very much representative uh we
don't have any other pink cards up here
but is the department is it represented
on the representative you've got
upgraded again Diana Fenton
we will just need a card for a penguin
for technical information you got it
I'm so pleased with myself good morning
everyone my name is Diana Fenton I'm an
attorney with the Department of
Education you will soon learn that I
usually come before you with information
as it pertains to child safety and
criminal background checks code of
conduct issues I'm a former prosecutor
from another lifetime so uh that is my
only skill set so Frank edelboot said
you're going to do child safety
initiatives I'm here today uh filling in
for Caitlin Davis so I assure you I have
really big shoes to fill and I cannot
answer all the questions that she will
answer for you next Tuesday on the 17th
when you go to the um training at
Granite State but this bill uh was a
request by the Department of Education
so thank you to representative Mooney
for bringing it forward
this bill is in response to a law change
from 2016 which quite simply made the
reporting requirement uh a non-issue it
made it moot the change allowed for a
warrant to be drawn so there was no need
for a report as to your question that
you alluded to all of this information
as to charter school funding is on the
Department's website
and so this report requirement is just
taking up staff time that could be
utilized for other things and so that's
why the department asked that this bill
be brought forward
um again I am playing the role of
Caitlin Davis big shoes to fill as I'm
sure you know and I'm going to request
that any questions technical questions
about charter school funding be deferred
until uh the presentation next week if
that's okay so I waived a Caitlyn as she
was going up to Laconia today when I was
driving South she was driving north did
you pass fire yeah well I saw her going
up the road when the two lanes were
closed but uh so this is a bill that's
being put forth it's one of those
technical bills put forth by the
department correct talking it's a
technical change Bill what will happen
is the department will identify areas in
the statute that are no longer necessary
they might conflict with other laws or
in this particular instance another law
was passed which made this unnecessary
but because it's still on the books it
has to be followed and it's taking up
staff time that could be utilized for
other purposes so that's why it if you
want to you could call it a technical
bill or we often refer to them as
cleanup bills okay for representative
cordelli do you have a question yes
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
attorney Fenton for being here
do you happen to know the 2016
bill or RSA that was impacted by that
bill
I do not off the top of my head but I
can look in the source notes
um I'm the lucky one who has the brand
new book so I can look in the source
notes and get you that information thank
you thank you so we're gonna get some
new books this year all right
I Knew by bringing my book up here I
would uh cause problems well I'm going
to ask that question where
representative Tanner is going to ask
that question um
just now and I can fill you in later
okay thank you I'll just for to
representative cordelli on that okay
thank you all very much so
representative did you have a question
thanks very much Mr really a quick
question um
um you had mentioned that um that it's
it's really uh
you know sort of the the report to the
fiscal committee's moot because
uh there's a warrant to be drawn and I
see that in language I'm not quite sure
what that does in terms of replacing the
report but you said that there's a
there's a there's there is a report on
the doe website is there any difference
between the report on the doe I guess
there's two parts of the question any
difference on the the report on the doe
website compared with what is currently
being presented to the fiscal committee
and is there a statutory requirement for
the doe to uh to make this report
available on the doe website those are
great questions to the best of my
knowledge there's no difference as to
the information that's in the report
that might be a difference in as to the
formatting but not to the information
um
I'm not sure what statutory Authority if
any requires the report to be on the
website I do know that most of the
information the department deals with is
public information and our website is a
great resource to find all the
information that we have in terms of
funding and the different projects that
we do so
it is our go-to to put that information
on the website to make it publicly
available even if there's not a
statutory requirement to do so here I'm
not sure if there is a statutory
requirement for that I'm going to defer
to Caitlin Davis on that sure because I
you know I I yeah I just thought it
would be it would be good to uh to learn
that on Tuesday next week because I
think it'd be important to uh to members
of the public not to lose any
transparent Financial transparency when
it comes to any any payments to um to
schools
absolutely and the department agrees
with that completely and to the best of
my knowledge that information is already
publicly available and this is just
really as I mentioned one of those
cleanup bills to recognize we do have
limited staff time and the information
is already there so uh we appreciate
that okay
do you have a question yes thank you Mr
chair
um from what I could find on a report
the charter school accountability plan
is based on goals and objectives I
didn't see anything that requires them
to report uh an update on the funding
um so I guess my question would be
um whether you can answer it or we wait
till Caitlyn is where's the
accountability for for charter schools
in terms of their Public Funding
I'm going to defer to Caitlin okay thank
you appreciate that
[Music]
would be nice if you could convey these
types of questions to Caitlin ahead of
time so we can you know she can be
prepared to respond to us on Tuesday I
will certainly do that thank you
any other questions for
attorney Fenton
you're off the hook thank you very much
we don't have any other pink cards on
this from the public is there anybody
else here in the public would like to
speak on this
not seeing anybody we're going to close
this hearing
and and what we will do is we will hang
those here for about 10 minutes we can't
start the next one until
10 20.
so you can get up and stretch if you
want
and another thing folks you can get up
anytime you need to get up
in in a hearing just be polite in doing
so when you come back
always go back to chair after somebody
has stopped speaking not during the time
that they're speaking
good question yeah is this where all
these commentary so those suggest those
are just basically for boosting
attendance today you would Circle those
then you would just do what you've done
here you've got the first one repeat
what it's about and then you should say
it turn again yeah that's fine that's
all you have to do okay you're good I
just want to make sure good morning just
a couple of those were passed down
about
representative cordelli will be
presenting the bill we've had some bills
at times just for a quick note
where we didn't have either the prime
sponsor or the co-sponsor present
I would say to another Committee Member
take the bill introduce the bill we'd
introduce it and close it so we had our
hearing
so what we'll do right now I'll welcome
representative cordelli to our our
hearing today on 147. welcome uh thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you committee
members uh for the record I'm Glenn
cordelli representing Tuftonboro
Wolfeboro endosopy in the beautiful
Lakes Region and uh I will introduce
this bill which is relative to the
membership of the advisory committee on
the education of students with
disabilities I have been a member of
that uh committee for the past two terms
um it is a large committee that is
mandated by the federal government under
idea
um
as I mentioned it's a large committee
there are currently I think 36 members
so it is sometimes uh difficult to get
business done in a concise time with
that number of members
and the prime sponsor of this bill is
making two adjustments to the membership
um the first
um is related to the Department of
Corrections representative
currently in our law the uh there's a
department from extreme representative
from the Department of Corrections Plus
a representative from a County
Correctional Facility uh federal law
just requires someone from the
Department of Corrections not someone
from a County facility as well so um the
prime sponsor is adjusting that to be in
line with federal law and not require
someone from the correctional facility
to be present
my recollection from meetings is that
in many if not most cases there is no
one present from a County Correctional
Facility anyway
the second adjustment is to add someone
to the advisory committee and that is a
health care provider who has who does
work with special needs children
um to offer advice on questions on
disabilities that might come up during
discussions of the committee
so basically that is the intent of the
bill and I'd be glad to take any
questions thank you very much
representative are there any questions
of Representative cordelli
not yes reps in the hall thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm just curious so you did
mention that they don't show up anyway
um but are they okay with this change
at the corrections
uh I am not sure I I have not been
present at a meeting when this is
um uh been discussed
um I know that the uh Committee of the
council has um uh a list of possible uh
bills that uh uh impact uh children with
disabilities in their education uh but I
have not been present for any discussion
about any bill in particular
thank you yes representative
thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you Miss representative cardelli
you mentioned the addition was someone
who was specialized in working with
children with disabilities but it
doesn't have the words with disabilities
in the the text here
uh thank you for the question
um I I think online uh six and seven
in the heading of the new paragraph it
does mention disabilities uh but
possibly not in um my nine or ten as as
you indicate
follow-up question yes so which
interpretation is give is would be taken
then
um actually what we'll go into statute
is line nine and ten and D
um
if the committee would like to offer an
amendment to uh put that uh the
pediatrician would specialize in working
or does work with children with
disabilities
um I would not see a problem with that
I I think there might be additional
amendments anyway relative to the
membership of the council representative
I was just gonna say that there needs to
be an amendment anyways because it says
who is our the r didn't get struck and
so while doing that it would be fine
with you and the and the the put with
disabilities in as well
I was not an English major but I think
that would be appropriate thank you
a lot of times too when this goes back
legislative services will correct those
grammatical punctuation type errors are
miscues
where the chairman might yeah that's
correct reps represent Cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um it says one representative from the
Department of Corrections and one
representative from a County
Correctional Facility both of whom are
responsible for administering the
provision of special education services
do you do you know what the difference
is between the different populations
that are serviced by these two
departments
um to a degree but I I know also that
some County correctional facilities also
House State prisoners
um but there are different
responsibilities and statutes uh
impacting uh the state facility versus
County facilities
and different programs that are offered
between
um
whether uh you know there are
differences in terms of the population
of prisoners with disabilities
um I I think that that would be on an
individual basis
um
but I I think my interpretation is that
it's uh repetitive to have both
especially when we in the commission
committee is so large to begin with
I also know there's I think 23 parents
on it too which might be kind of on what
we'll leave well actually the Federal
Law requires there to be a majority of
the committee members uh to be parents
thank you
further questions of Representative
cordelli yes represent whitcock
thank you Mr chairman thank you just
following up on my seat mates uh
question so uh when you send this back
to correct the grammar on line four are
you going to add in on line 9 at 10
after the word children with
disabilities so we're talking about
someone specialize with disabilities we
can we can yes we can do that and I
think that there might be some
additional adjustments um
along the line with an amendment okay
yes you may follow up thank you
um in in line ten Ender nine and
entertainment it suggests a pediatrician
but does that preclude any other health
care provider this is just just like so
just maybe a pediatrician or it could be
a someone who works in a nursing office
or could that be true
or an r and it doesn't be a pediatrician
that's my question uh representative
um uh I I I imagine it could be but we
can also talk to the prime sponsor
um after this uh uh hearing and see what
her original intent was in specifying
the pediatrician okay thank you thank
you Mr chair
representative cascaden thank you Mr
chair uh just clarification uh
representative on the federal laws
requiring representation from
Corrections
is it requiring someone from both state
level Corrections and County Corrections
or one or the other uh I believe it's
specified state
so a County
Corrections could substitute for a state
person or my recollection and reading
idea was that it was a state corrections
Department official that is in state law
teaching me in federal law okay
my follow-up on Health Care
um certainly is a great idea to
recommend a health care provider and
wondered if
as you pursue the details that
representative Woodcock just asked is
that nurse practitioners and
um Physicians assistance so maybe the
term could be used as health care
provider
thank you
thank you are there further questions
thank you very much representative
cordelli
uh representative patab I noticed you
just entered the room uh do you have a
pink card filled out
is it coming up
okay so I'm I'm gonna ask representative
come forward right now seeing that
you're
the prime sponsor I believe
representative cordelli did a pretty
good job of explaining but let's see
here it is okay yeah
Welcome to our committee
thank you thank you for having me Mr
chair and to the rest of the committee
um I apologize that I was a few minutes
late here and thank you to
representative cordelli uh house bill
147. would you please just State your
your name and what your rep who you
represent that's just the formality for
the record my name is for the record my
name is representative Caitlin kutab I
represent Rockingham District 17 and I'm
from Windham okay there you go thank you
so this is in relation to the state
advisory committee uh bird for children
with disabilities the purpose of this
committee is to provide policy Guidance
with respect to special education and
related services for children with
disability in the state
as previously mentioned by
representative cortelli this this bill
is replacing one of three Corrections
Officers positions with a volunteer
health care worker specializing in
children such as a pediatrician my
intent was to have it
be open enough that considering this is
a volunteer position that we would
be able to fill it for years to come and
so I would
like it ideally to be a pediatrician or
a developmental pediatrician or a nurse
practitioner and so the intent is for it
to be a graduate level provider and not
for
let's say an L A or something of that
sort
I do feel that having this type of a
position would help to enhance the
overall benefit of the committee
the committee is
rather large it has a 22
non-parent State positions and then it
has 23 parent slash individuals with
disability positions and as mentioned it
is a requirement under federal law that
the majority of the committee be
parents or individuals with disabilities
so in adding a position I wanted to be
sure to take one off that maybe wasn't
required and so under federal law there
are certain requirements it does require
a state's corrections officer but it
doesn't require a County corrections
officer I do believe that that is an
underserved population and should
certainly be represented and so having
two would still allow for that
representation
the pediatrician would be able to
represent a much wider population
including that very same subset that the
County officer could also represent
happy to take very much representative
are there questions from the committee
for the representative yes
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
kutab um I don't know if you heard the
the discussion just when you came in but
when representative cordelli introduced
the bill he talked about
um you're looking for a health care
provider who specialized in working with
children with disabilities that text
isn't in the your your proposal and we
wondered if that's your intent are you
looking for someone who specializes with
children or with children with
disabilities
sure so
uh
to answer the question better
a pediatrician who is working with
children although
not specializing specifically in
disabilities does have a lot of vast
experience treating children with
disabilities oftentimes they're the ones
who are doing regular developmental
screenings and they may be part of the
team that's working with other
Specialists to diagnose certain
disabilities with children and so I
didn't want to make it so specific that
it had to be like a developmental
pediatrician because to my knowledge
there's currently I believe three
developmental pediatricians at Elliott
one who is only part-time at Dartmouth
and then there's a few nurse
practitioners and so I didn't want it to
be so
confining that it could only be you know
a handful of people within the state and
so I do feel a pediatrician with
experience in all pediatricians should
certainly have experience in working
with children with disabilities as well
as a nurse practitioner who's who's
specializing in Pediatrics a PNP would
have
a vast amount of experience working with
children with disabilities follow-up
question Mr chairman yes thank you for
taking this so then the text as it
stands is more of your intent than
adding the words with disabilities to
Children specializing with children with
disabilities
yes other than I it probably would make
sense possibly to clarify that it should
be a graduate level provider because the
intent was for it to be either a
pediatrician or a nurse practitioner and
not
you know
something less than that
okay other further questions of the
representative thank you very much thank
you we have two cards remember uh
remaining
um Mariah Ryan I would like to speak on
this bill we also have Rebecca Fredette
who is from the Department of Education
special education that is here
um I see Rebecca you have asked for 10
minutes to speak or is it just boiled
down to you know technical support
okay thank you
thank you
okay I'd like to invite up uh Miss Ryan
good morning my name is Maura Ryan and I
represent parents in the state of New
Hampshire of children with disabilities
um I'm here to speak
um
in support of hb147 I'm a four-term
member of the sac committee at present
as a parent representative
um we've had a doctor on our committee
in the past who is very instrumental in
getting assistance for children with
disabilities
um and unfortunately she wasn't able to
continue but she was very good at
bringing information regarding testing
and disabilities particularly if parents
aren't knowledgeable on those subject
matters I also wanted to point out that
there's sort of been a Divergence
between medical disability and
educational management of disability so
having some type of medical knowledge of
testing would be very beneficial
the law regarding the state advisory
committee and the composition is 300.168
um which states that there has to be a
State Correctional person on the
committee we currently have three
Correctional members on the committee so
it is a bit of Overkill
um
I think one of the other issues too was
that we only have one County uh
Correctional person and some of the
other counties were saying like why
didn't we get representation so I think
the state overall is a better
representation I do agree with the
suggestion of a higher degree
level medical person
um but the purpose of the state advisory
committee is to be a parent-led
committee and it is to have parent voice
on students with disabilities because
they live with it so I'm here in support
of that bill and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you very much Mariah are there any
questions yes represent Damon thank you
Mr chair
um I just want a clarification the
draft of the bill speaks about two
Correctional positions as has been
discussed but both you and
representative could top reference three
so who's the third what are the
qualifications of third party
the other correctional officer so
there's one who specializes in Adult
Services one who Services State
Correctional populations and there's a
County correctional person so there are
three at present
further questions yes
so the one who represents the adult
population is also at the state level I
believe Federal level
thank you
are there further questions yes
representative Cornell Thank you thank
you for taking my question you said that
the medical person would have medical
knowledge of testing I'm not quite sure
what you mean
so when your child gets diagnosed with a
disability they go through a battery of
tests those could be things like a towel
four a whisk a Wyatt things of that
nature which I happen to be a registered
nurse so I understand what those things
are but the average parent doesn't and
in the past a lot of um disability
groups will try and approach parents
after their children have been diagnosed
through pediatricians offices to try and
help them manage and deal with the
situation at hand and sort of turn it
into something positive and get supports
so they're connected and I think in the
past historically they've been more
connected but there's been a little bit
of a Divergence as management of medical
disability has changed
versus educational disability they've
sort of gone on two different paths does
that answer your question thank you yes
thank you very much we have the
department which we if you have
technical questions or information you
may need
is there a need for more information on
this at this time from the Department
thank you very much Mariah thank you
uh does the Diana or Rebecca is there
something that the department wants to
convey to us on this bill or are we good
fine once you come forward then Rebecca
welcome back thank you good morning
thank you for having me
um representative Ladd my name is
Rebecca Fredette I'm the state director
of special education at the Department
of Education
I oversee all of special education in
the state of New Hampshire sorry I have
a slight cold so I apologize
um just for clarification
um
yes we do have two Representatives on
the committee from both the County
correctional facility and the um state
prison
um there are I would just note that
there are differences in their
responsibilities in regards to Ida I
believe somebody had asked that question
I couldn't see so I'm not sure who it
was um for the state facility they are
required to provide education through
the Granite State High School that they
have within their facility for County
correctional facilities they have to
collaborate with leas to provide special
education so it is a different role but
they do both work in the correctional
facility
um
the other one was the three
Representatives I I guess I was unclear
on the three Representatives as well
there is the state facility there's the
county facility and we had previously
had one that was part of the sununu
Youth Services Center but they do not
have a representative at this point and
have chosen to send somebody from dcyf
um so I don't know if that was the third
representative so I just wanted to
clarify those pieces from just the
conversations that we had but if you
have any other questions I'm willing to
answer them thank you very much are
there any questions yes representative
luno
thanks for thank you very much and uh
and thanks for joining us this morning
uh uh Rebecca
um
How are um how are people uh I guess
um recommended to be nominated to the um
uh the this the the SEC so there's um
two ways that they can be appointed by
the governor they can go to the SAC
meeting and express their interest on
being on the committee and then the sack
through their bylaws um
State advisory committee acronym Sac I
apologize they can come to they ask that
you come to two meetings and then that
you submit a resume and then they vote
on it at the SEC at the second meeting
as to whether you would be appointed to
or sent to the governor and the
commissioner for appointment you can
also send a letter directly to the
governor and ask for an appointment
there it does come back to us so that
the commissioner is aware of it and we
do make sure that they would meet the
requirements of being on the on the
committee but then it would go back to
the governor and then be appointed
through there
thanks very much Mr that's actually very
helpful to know thanks did you have
a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you I have
two actually
um good morning how are you doing yes
it's a horrible place for that by the
way Mr chair uh that being said one
question is the membership capped at 36
so the membership um is to however many
required individuals so the required the
correctional facility a state a special
ed director
um and then you fill all of those
positions and you have to have 51 of
parents so if you so you always have to
have more parents than you do the other
positions
thank you um the follow-up to that is uh
you talked a minute ago it was wonderful
because I didn't understand it at all
actually so the state prison does the
high school program within the facility
okay thank you and the county
representative of the Lea does the does
the IEP for students that are within
under lsnas right so if we eliminated
the county uh position County correct
position from this membership would that
mean that those youngsters wouldn't have
uh someone representing them in terms of
their IEP or creating those things no
they would still have represent they
wouldn't have representation on this
committee but they do still have
representation from their school
districts that the County correctional
facilities work with Okay so there's a
process by which they they work with us
in collaboration with us to identify
students that may be identified as
having a disability and then they would
reach out to the Lea that so wherever
that child or or young adult lived
before they were incarcerated they would
reach out to that local Education Agency
and they would collaborate with them to
ensure that they were getting the
services that they may need okay just
one more if I may as a chair yes so so
just to clarify that so that means uh
assuming this bill goes through with
with the deletion of that County
representative then a youngster who is
incarcerated in the county facility
um would the county facilities
responsibility then to what you're
telling me if I understand this the
county facilities responsibility then
somewhere there would be responsible to
get back to the home school Sunday
District
that's what they already do they are so
the the committee position doesn't um
oversee any of that it's just that it's
a representative from one of the
counties and they rotate that through
the different counties so that they have
some you know they have a voice yeah
thank you for the clarity thank you Mr
chairman uh represent Woodcock that it's
on a good point that's very difficult
sometimes for counties to track that
down a person is
done something down in Hanover but was
not uh a resident of Hanover but a
resident of Plymouth and you've got to
determine whether it's an IEP whether
they've graduated yet all those things
come in the bundle and I know that where
I've been on the executive committee at
Grafton County it's been a real chore
trying to find out where the the
resident district is oftentimes less
it's in Vermont
a lot of questions here with this whole
thing but this is another topic are
there any other questions for Rebecca
yes representative hall or Damon I mean
excuse me it's okay thank you
and thank you for taking my question
um
do you have any data on what portion of
the students with disabilities are in
County facilities versus State
facilities so I would not have the
numbers on the state facilities and then
the information that I have because it
is for the correctional facilities
because it's such a small number it is
considered personally identifiable
information so I would have to look to
see if I could put that out but really
what we do with the county is they send
us newly incarcerated individuals within
the age range and then we say yes you
should reach out to Concord School
District or you should reach out to this
this is the last one we have of record
but they are very small numbers
thanks very much we're right at the end
of our time here so uh if there are any
other real questions that we have we can
ask them of the department when we meet
on on Tuesday so thank you very much
we don't have any other cards uh on 147
here so with that I'm going to close the
hearing
and the next hearing which we have which
we're going to move right into
foreign
scheduled for 10 40 uh
hb102 102 local requiring high schools
to include instruction the nature and
history of communism
are you ready go ahead
okay so I'd like to invite forward the
prime sponsor of the bill that would be
uh representative Moffett
welcome back to education
great to be back in 207 with for the
action
thank you
and it is going to be back to see some
familiar faces uh for the record my name
is Mike moffatt I'm the state
representative from Merrimack District
for the towns of Canterbury Loudoun so
to get right through this
um this bill simply requires
an hour one hour of classroom attention
to be paid to the uh
origin and nature of communism
it's been inspired by numerous
conversations with parents and citizens
who are very concerned that the Young
Folks today do not know some some
important things that they do need to
know in terms of
uh how our world has come to be
many schools do not teach history like
they used to many schools do not teach
history it is a social science major of
course I'm distressed by that as are
others so anyway there are at least four
Uh current and former house members
colleagues who have first seen
experience with with Communism
uh such as the former member of this
committee representative sodi whose
parents came from or refugees from
Hungary after the 1956 Revolution there
uh current rep exploration he uh he
still has relatives in Kiev cave in the
Ukraine uh former rep Michael yokovic
whose family escaped from the former
Soviet Union
in one of the spilled sponsors uh who
couldn't be here today I'll take some of
his time uh representative Jose
Campbells who was a refugee from
Castro's communist Cuba so like any
worthy measure I think this is a worthy
measure this bill invites some questions
and I'll try to quickly run through them
uh now and and later if there are any
questions so question why communism why
not uh a period of instruction on uh
Mussolini or islamo fascism Aryan Nation
Q Anon whatever
and good question in these and other
violent movements rate attention and
study but to try to include all these in
in the statute would just simply be
unwieldy
educated citizens in America today need
to understand the or what communism is
and how that political and economic
system has shaped our history and
profoundly affects all of us today
uh dictionary definition of communism
political Theory derived from Karl Marx
I think I hope most all of you know the
basics advocating class Warfare
resulting in all property being state
owned
involves a centrally planned economy as
opposed to one that reflects Market
forces
so without exception communist countries
depend on vast networks of secret police
to impose party will on everyone and
while there are different gradations and
shades of Communism Yugoslavia was a
little was was different from
Czechoslovakia it was different from
Soviet Union so
it Still Remains a totalitarian ideology
incompatible without it's an atheist
totalitarian ideology incompatible many
of us think with America and our values
and our system of government
so throughout the 20th century and into
the current sensory this incompatibility
I just mentioned
reflected in hot Wars and cold Wars
repression Gulag prison camp starvation
endless violent conflict subversion
the union of the Soviet Socialist
republics was born violence and
bloodshed after the 1917 Russian
Revolution it then established a common
turn
um and that was the Communist
International to spread communism
worldwide by whatever means necessary
whatever the cost slavery replaced by
the common form so let's try to
quantify this movement in terms of lives
in 2010 professor
Stephen Rosenfield wrote in red
Holocaust
that the contradictions the internal
contradictions of communist regimes
resulted in the deaths the killing of at
least 60 million people
at least and that doesn't in perhaps
tens of millions more and that doesn't
include like the 25 million Soviets who
died
due to the machinations of uh Stalin and
Hitler who get together and started
World War II
um
Nazi by the way is short for national
socialism but communism predated Nazi
Nazism is a totalitarian ideology in
many ways very similar in some
fundamental ways they're different
that's why they went to war in 1941 but
Hitler and the Nazis long gone
although that movement remains and
Stalin's Legacy remains indeed
communist nuclear missiles from China to
Korea to Siberia appointed at us now as
we speak there are communist nuclear
missiles pointed at us and some of us
don't think much about it some of us
don't even know that and that's one of
the reasons why we want to focus a
little attention on this
speaking of nuclear missiles I know
there are others here besides me as I
look around at least a few who remember
the Cuban Missile Crisis of 1962 I'm
sure I know at least a few of you I was
seven years old
and for a week or two weeks
when I was in the second grade it was
one of the most it might have been the
most terrifying time of my life and and
in that when you're seven years old and
all the grown-ups are scared to death
that nuclear missiles are going to come
in and and kill us all really uh that's
something that stays with you so I'm
talking about it today
my dad at that time in 1962 explained
that if if or when the bombs came uh
we'd I'll quickly go to the underground
Fallout shelters beneath the Groveton
paper mill I don't know if you had the
same guidance represent piles also from
Groveton
to the so yeah so we're ready to go to
the following shelter in the bronze came
and they didn't come we survived that
crisis but there were many lessons to be
learned and how many high school
graduates today have a hot clue hot clue
is an expression I get from the chair
have a hot clue
um
about the Cuban Missile Crisis I won't
put I won't put representative McDonald
on the spot I want to ask but I won't
uh because I'm sure but but how many
students have a hot clue about the Cuban
Missile Crisis that impacted some of us
so profoundly you're the Korean War the
Vietnam War our own chair again
representative in Vietnam where
Communists tried to kill him you imagine
trying to kill such a nice man as that I
mean
and that's history and out of Vietnam
came the boat people
how many high schoolers today know about
the boat people who are the boat people
can you imagine a Communist Regime so
heinous that hundreds or thousands of
Vietnamese get into boats and sailed off
in the ocean because
they would rather face drowning Pirates
rapists on the high seas than have to
live under communism this is just a
short time ago
again representative lab was in Vietnam
um
and then there were those lucky boat
people who came to America
and again but so many Americans don't
know this history history is not taught
like it should be I think many of us
think next door to Vietnam is Cambodia
if you look at a map uh you know who who
knows where Cambodia is I'm afraid a lot
of people don't even know where it is or
why it's important what happened there's
next to Vietnam
between 1975 when the Communists took
over just a short time ago really
in 1979 during their four-year period
over 2 million cambodians were murdered
by the communist genocide classic
genocide
how many Young Americans today know what
the Killing Fields or The Killing Fields
of Cambodia some of you know some I know
some of you know I'm aware of it is that
important to know why these millions of
people just a short time ago in Cambodia
were murdered
and yet people don't know do they care
they should care and someone care if if
we would do a little bit to raise
awareness about some some recent history
that they should know Ronald Reagan
correctly called the Soviet Union a evil
empire or he was right communist entity
created the Iron Curtain how many high
school students are who I think all of
us know what the Iron Curtain was
but how did it come about why was it why
was there an iron curtain how does that
affect us today affects us a lot again
representative saudi's family came from
behind the Iron Curtain he's not here
this term
but if folks with some Curious you might
ask him that question
so anyway to try to finish this up I'll
use a minute or two representative
Campbell's time he was very passionate
about this as a refugee from Cuba
himself a member of this house
co-sponsor of this bill I faced
communist Weaponry myself I was my
battalion's anti-mac officer in Kuwait
1991 Desert Sun and the enemy had these
t-62 t-72 tags pointed at us which we
took out these are tanks manufactured by
the Soviets Communists built these
weapons that were shooting at us the
scud missiles that flew over our heads
uh they killed two not too many people
from Arabia to Israel uh communist
weapons so how many of us are concerned
that so many people don't have that that
hot clue about who Stalin and Lenin were
or Mao iron curtains Sputnik Bay of Pigs
Cuban Missile Crisis glass nose
perestroika the rosenbergs
why did we execute this this American
couple husband and wife executed why
something that Bears discussion I think
today what is a gulag
what was the Cold War as I said earlier
so
the philosopher George Santana said and
I know you've heard this
those who do not remember the past or
condemned to repeat it there's much
truth to that but how can you remember
the past important past if you don't
study freedom of history courses
across the street
Elizabeth
maybe met her the wonderful building
right across the street the New
Hampshire Historical Society
um Sometimes some of the youngsters who
come to visit the state house go there
after they visit the state house and
Elizabeth told me that uh she gets very
sad when she quickly realizes that the
the youngsters and holsters who visit
right across the street I've only been
there once and I don't know if you've
ever been a it it's wonderful
uh it costs seven bucks but
um so
folks like her who I've spoken with and
others
um are afraid and Disturbed and I say
it's right they're fearful about our
country's future when so many extras
just don't know
where we came from and things that they
shouldn't especially Ukraine today uh
Vladimir Putin was in his a communist I
mean he was the head of the Soviet KGB
and you know he he had his country
invade Ukraine does that affect people
today heck yes you know from the big oil
prices to he's threatened to use nuclear
missiles I I I'm sure most of you know
that do you think our young people
or everyone should have a little bit
more awareness of the the potential of
these nuclear missiles that he's
threatening to use enveloping escalating
into a nuclear war so this proposed
statute does not require any course it
doesn't even require an assessment it
simply asked it's still to spend at
least one hour
embedded or however they want to do it
locally one hour to just start the
process of raising some basic awareness
of this subject of the history and
nature of Communism and how would it
impacts us today
so implementing this would be subject to
local control if it moves forward which
obviously I hope it does
and we would expect that uh if it did
before doe as they always do would issue
a little advisory or some basic guidance
in terms of helping districts to
implement
the uh the statute now I've heard of her
today that some folks worry though if
this were to move forward fair question
what about proselytation what if some
Marxist educator takes this hour and and
tries to uh
provide a shade or a biased view of
choice this what how communism came
about what it is it's fair question I
don't I I don't worry too much about
that I I think that discretion is good I
think out of this one hour if if you
move it forward
this window requirement many other hours
will flow from that and and discussion
will locally will happen uh about this
and then the questions about you know
why don't we have an hour on Queue or
not
good question well Q10 doesn't have uh
nuclear missiles pointed at us for one
thing so anyway I trust the districts
and uh I don't worry excessively about
the hour being abused
so anyway that's that's about it local
control I'm sure this uh will have some
robust discussion thanks for your time
and for uh letting me say if you want
thank you very much
um are there questions for our
representative representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much representative Moffett for
joining us this morning
um at the uh at the start of the uh I
feel like I've just had an hour crash
course in um in communism uh but at the
start of it you mentioned um you you
made a comment schools don't teach
history where'd that come from
sure thanks for your question the
question representative Bruno that's uh
maybe we call it in a slight
exaggerational embellishment uh that's
what people say to me you know schools
of course they do they're all different
some teach it better than others stem
has been the emphasis in uh in so many
people have said and you can do the
research schools curriculum do not any
longer include in many cases uh U.S
history or world history uh and thank
you for nodding your head is
yes let's put it this way history is not
taught like it used to be it's been it's
being taught less and that's that's the
concern
did it follow up on that a quick one
um are you are you aware of the um the
current status of the uh the
Department's effort to revise the social
studies curriculum in New Hampshire oh
great thank you for the question very
much I've actually had a little bit of
input there and I support that and I'm
pleased that that's that is is happening
and I hope it leads to uh some more
attention in this all right so and uh so
can you can you address that Rick yeah
yeah I I have a question here because we
are going to we have about 20 more 20
minutes on this
um I'm concerned the area that I have
some concern with is there are students
that have IEPs which are and you say
every student here and there's some
conditions where a child may have
multiple handicap uh situations written
in and or or is uh placed in a uh a
hospital situation or a residential
place basement and for for some severe
issues that's one one exception I'm
concerned about the other is that we
have a lot of transition between our
school districts in this state and
throughout this country as far as
movement
and we have some students that come in
during the middle of the senior year
and I know you're talking about a
one-hour course but if the student says
I've taken U.S history and we talked
about that and it was an accredited U.S
history course through the New England
Association of schools and colleges
would that suffice for your one hour of
uh required instruction if they've had
or if they've had a course specifically
in world history
where that they could show that yes it
did touch upon this particular subject
area thank you for the question Mr
Sheriff uh to answer that uh the point
of this one hour it's not a course and
you mentioned you said the word course
it's not a corset so one hour period of
information on on this uh it's like the
uh the Civics measure which we passed
which is now long
um where and now that you have the bill
you obviously can do whatever you you do
with it but in the Civics management we
specifically mentioned that uh special
needs students you know special
Arrangements could be made for special
need students
if there's a one hour video it's if this
move forward I'm sure somebody would
create one that could be shown if the
district's ordered so that one hour
video could be shown uh to such a
transfer or anywhere very easily in my
view
I I and just to follow up though when I
talk about course of course you talk
about course in the bill here because it
may be embedded in a course right right
and so if a student can say this was
embedded in the course that I had where
I got credit for graduation based upon
the military compact which we have
signed uh with the other 49 states on
top of ours
um so would that then suffice
as meeting this particular end sure
thank you it's a good question and the
answer right is it lines with guidance
departments you know I've been in high
schools and colleges so when transfer
occurs the receiving institution whether
it's a college or High School the the
registrar or the guidance office
evaluates the TR the course of being
transferred and locally they would make
that decision as to if if they think it
did satisfy the one hour requirement
then good to go if they think it didn't
then they would need to have the student
uh watch the one hour video or or be in
the session
thank you further questions
representative Allison
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question two quick ones one uh
were any social studies teachers uh
interviewed talked to about this
particular Bill did you have contact
with any of them before you put this
together oh sure I'm in touch again that
was my my area and I'm in touch uh
routinely all the time with former
current social studies teachers and yeah
I none of them are are testifying today
but to your question yeah absolutely
yeah okay so one more follow-up uh and
just looking at the uh number of topics
that you listed in your testimony or
Gulag rosenberg's vote people Killing
Fields iron Curtin and a whole host of
other things
are you pretty clear that all of that
will be covered in a one-hour course
whether it's over one hour period of
time sometime during a high school
experience or frankly it could be done
at Junior High it could be done in
kindergarten I guess according to the
bill sure that's a great question and my
answer is uh yes there's a lot there and
to put into an hour
again this should be implemented locally
if it moves forward and what I see
happening is perhaps a handout would
like uh a couple dozen terms that we
just mentioned things to know a few
dates a few names and and uh you know
these are things that on on your own
students that you might want to uh the
research investigate read about on your
own and that would be part of the one
hour and then you know I'm sure some
students would be suddenly if they
realize uh the importance of this on
their own I might I would hope they
would go beyond that hour and and find
out and learn more
thank you thank you Mr chairman
okay we I'll take two more uh
representative Woodcock and then
represent Tanner but we're gonna have to
get out we have other people who want to
testify in this bill as well so so let's
uh go rep some woodcock
oh okay
represent Tanner
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Woodcock uh and thank you
representative Moffett for taking my
question my questions about local
control and uh you briefly mentioned it
as you were sure you were going to hear
it so I didn't want you to be
disappointed
but it is my understanding that
curriculum is really the purview of the
local school district and as I say all
the time the school district that I was
from has a robust
American history course American
government course
um courses that combined English and
social studies together to study
different areas and
um
the different leas have curriculum
committees as well
so I think if someone was really
in a local area very concerned about
this particular subject I would ask that
they contact their local school district
because that's where curriculum's made
and also isn't this an unfunded mandate
that so my two questions is isn't it the
purview of the local school district to
set curriculum and isn't it an unfunded
mandate because once you put in an hour
of this you've got to take an hour of
something else out or if you add it as
an extra hour that's you know time is
money sure thanks for your question real
quick um yeah I'm big on local control
however there we uh routinely look at
the rsa's how many rsas are you know the
this committee the state of New
Hampshire
routinely provide input and guidance and
direction to the districts on what's an
educated student what needs to be part
of curriculum
um so I there's plenty of precedent for
the State uh taking some interest and
that's one of the reasons why this is
such a I don't see a one-hour uh period
of discussion or video being a an
unfunded mandated at all I don't think
yeah I would take some time but I don't
think we need to hire anybody or spend
huge amounts of money to implement this
is why we kept it to a to an hour just
to uh get this on the radar screens and
and yes I know every District had
somewhere than others have some courses
in social sciences but the reason that
this has come forth is because many of
us believe or know uh I mean if we could
quiz people I won't do it in here if we
could Chris people and just some of the
basic things I said earlier I I believe
is that most my sense
uh anecdotally in and from surveys that
are done uh young people do not know
things that I and many of us think they
crucially need to know anyway that's a
lot sorry mysterious long answer but
thank you for the question
representative woodcock
thank you Mr chair and uh brother Martha
good to see you again I think
um but I I I I say that uh in Australia
it's like I agree with representative
Tanner from the from the get-go that
this is a local curriculum option uh to
start with but the the lady Fair
approach to one hour of instruction
somewhere sometime during it and with
nothing with accountability there's no
way to track that there's no way to say
you did it and honestly I mean any world
anywhere else of course any world
history course uh Congress any current
study that of the Ukrainian conflict
right now this is going to be there when
you say
um things it was just a short time ago a
short time ago but a short time ago for
you and perhaps representative Ladd and
myself but in reality that was five
decades ago
but not a short time ago now for maybe
someone like representative McDonald
maybe was uh moonlights ago right uh
anyhow my point is that this doesn't
have any accountability in it and that
if I was uh as I was Associated person
uh at that time I would say to my
principal I'm already covering communism
I can't do any of this in an hour
zero you can't do Killing Fields you
can't do you can't do any of that in an
hour it's sort of like a broad brush of
nothing it's just a waste of my time and
I'm just going to tell you Mr principle
yes we already cover it I was like I
just don't see the the value uh honestly
uh one trying to tell local school boys
to do things uh like this as we
shouldn't in my mind but beyond that we
have no accountability for it in the way
the bill is structured so I'm just
trying how are you going to get
accountability that happens
that's the question I was going to try
again I was waiting for this thank you
we got there you got there sure thank
you for that representative uh in terms
of accountability again this is not an
assessment that the intent of this is to
get this broad issue on the radar
screens of folks that we don't think
it's on their radar screens now
um and so just the fact that we're
having a hearing and we're having this
discussion and and people and and hello
to everybody who's out watching on
YouTube and who we'll watch on YouTube
later
um thanks for watching uh all these
people in committee and watching later
watching now are gonna are thinking and
they're saying uh what glass notes I
remember that and and your in your point
about it being five decades ago it's
it's very relative I know but in the
broad sweep of History five decades is a
heartbeat
um and but I'm very aware that that's uh
ancient history for for some of the yet
younger folks here hopefully that
responds somewhat to your your good
point
thank you very much I'm going to move on
to some of the other uh people want to
speak on this at this time thank you
very much representative moffatt thank
you all
um the next one would we'd like to have
like to have uh Jerry fruit please from
the New Hampshire school administrators
Association
this is Jerry's card
welcome
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee for indulging a few
moments of time with me this morning
my name is Jerry frule I'm the associate
executive director of the New Hampshire
school administrators Association and I
bring a gift to you it will be the gift
of time you don't have to report it on
those little reports that you have to
submit because I will not comment on
every single curriculum issue that comes
before this committee I would like the
testimony that I'm about to offer on
this one contemplated for any curriculum
topic really that comes before this
committee this session
um
with regards to 102 local
communism as well as other curriculum
bills cursive writing multiplication
tables teaching New Hampshire government
are all local decisions
there are without exception training
Staffing and fiscal implications for any
and all of these well-intended
curriculum bills and those costs are
borne by local taxpayers
many of these bills are duplicative of
what already happens in local schools
I've worked in seven different districts
throughout my 48-year career and can say
without question that each of these
topics of curriculum are taught in those
districts including conversations of
Communism New Hampshire government New
Hampshire Constitution recursive writing
multiplication tables all of those are
taught at local school districts levels
and if there is if you have some element
of doubt in that I would invite each and
every one of you to to visit your local
school district officials and have a
conversation about what is taught in any
of these areas that any citizen is
certainly welcome to do that there are
curriculum nights in districts there are
presentations by students there are open
houses there are parent conferences
there are curriculum materials available
I would encourage every one of you and
every legislator quite honestly to
become familiar with What's Done in
their local school districts before they
take action on any of these bills that
potentially are duplicative and uh
really something that that's already
happening in schools
I'd like to submit that the state
requirements themselves which are
currently under view as suggested by
representative Tana in the 306 and I
believe representative luno in the 306
review that is a vehicle for
requirements in communism or cursive
writing or multiplication tables or
whatever curriculum requirements that is
a vehicle to include those things those
topics in rules that school districts
have to follow currently every High
School in the state is required to offer
one unit in uni in United States history
and uh new in the United States and New
Hampshire history
a half unit of United States and New
Hampshire government
half unit in economics personal finance
a half unit in world history Global
Studies or geography in order for a
student to graduate from any High School
in the state at least those social
studies and that's the minimum
most school districts require more than
the minimum graduation requirements and
that's just in the area of social
studies so I would encourage you to
explore what your local districts
require as minimum because I would
submit that these topics are covered and
um
in what is already done
we appreciate the sponsor's interest in
a comprehensive and high quality public
education
and respect that again they work through
the rules process and their local school
district officials to ensure that these
types of topics are included in their
local educational program
we ask that this committee treat all
curriculum decisions as locally driven
decisions and that you find any bills
that we would require a state law to
implement these topics be considered in
expedient to legislate
and I would say thank you and invite any
questions thank you very much
representative luck you're willing to
take any questions I am willing to take
questions thank you represent Lucas
thank you
thank you for answering my question
um my understanding and and what you're
saying seems to go against what my
understanding is is that
this number one is not a local control
state
but Dylan's rule state that the towns
Etc are given
I told may you know whatever and that
part of the education committee's job is
to and also that rules aren't just made
up by
um departments but they come from the
legislative branch and that part of our
job is to say okay these things will be
taught and then within rules the doe
comes up with what the rules are and
then the local control do you have a
question to do it well I'm get there
quickly
but what you said was opposite of what I
understand and so I'm hoping you can
correct me or explain how curriculum now
is solely the responsibility of the
towns and the doe rules come from where
do they come from and how does the towns
decide what needs to be in the
curriculum Etc I I thought that was our
job and you've said it's not and I'm
wanting you to enlighten me thank you
for the question representative like us
and I will try to be brief in my
response
um
local curriculum decisions there are
local curriculum committees there are
folks in each district who work on
curriculum and what the content of
different areas are going to be
the state tells us what we have to what
topics we have to teach what courses if
you will and then within that and there
are elective courses that are developed
within each school system and then
within that it's up to the local folks
to determine how that curriculum is
going to be delivered that's that was my
understanding thank you thank you are
there further questions
not seeing it thank you very much thank
you for the opportunity uh we'll call
Becky Wilson right now
from the New Hampshire school boards
Association
this one right here good morning uh
House Education committee it's nice to
see everyone for the record I'm Becky
Wilson director of governmental
relations for the New Hampshire school
boards Association I would agree with
representative Woodcock that this is
right in the way of seeing everybody's
face so I will do my best
um we would like to thank the sponsors
of this bill for bringing forward topics
that they feel are of significant
importance
um however regardless of the
instructional content or concepts
proposed in these curriculum related
bills the ability for local school
boards to determine their local
curriculum is at the heart of nhsba's
opposition to these curriculum related
bills this bill adding specific and
detailed somewhat curriculum imposed on
all school districts goes against our
resolutions that support again the local
control and the local ability for school
boards to determine their local
curriculum that meets the needs of their
own Community with their community input
we would go back again to the fact that
school boards oversee An approved
curriculum within their communities and
it does not
necessarily work for every school
district to implement the same exact one
hour whatever that would be the school
board is required to ensure that their
programs cover as Mr fruit said certain
graduation requirements that are put
forth by the state but it is also up to
the local school board to determine
their own local diploma requirements as
Mr fruit said if you went to any of your
local school boards or your school
districts and looked at the requirements
for graduation there are oftentimes a
state approved graduation diploma which
will have certain requirements there are
also Local District requirements for
other diplomas there are also New
Hampshire Scholars diploma requirements
all of those are different at different
districts and that is because we believe
strongly that the school board should be
making those decisions with their local
Administration on the curriculum that is
taught in those districts
in addition we are as many of you are
aware undergoing a pretty significant
revision of the minimum standards for
public school approval the 306s if these
curriculum aspects are very important to
the legislature it would be important
for those things to be taken up as part
of that process as opposed to
individually looked at in terms of
skills and content throughout this
upcoming session that is going to drive
again to representative Lucas's point
the specifics that are given to
districts in terms of
very intentional skills and content that
need to be covered and how those things
are covered and what curriculum what
courses Etc to still be determined at
the local level and then to speak to a
point that was brought up earlier about
the social studies standards again those
have been to some extent revised several
years ago and I believe are sort of
stalled out at this point at the
department I'm not sure with the status
is of updating the social studies
standards from a state perspective but
that again is a place where this
particular content area could be
discussed on a much broader level with
input from larger communities teachers
students parents Etc so that's at the
heart of our opposition to these bills
it is not specific to the content but to
the decision-making ability of the local
school board to make those decisions and
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you very much Becky uh just as a a
information for the whole committee here
yesterday the legislative oversight
committee met
was it yesterday yeah it was yesterday
everything passed together and we looked
at the minimum standards Public School
approval and the academic standards
which are two different beasts and the
legislative oversight committee is
concerned that we look further into
social studies and the Improvement in
assessment materials used for that so
that is a topic there was a task force
At Doe that is now defunct it's gone
um the last time this stuff was reviewed
or updated was back over 12 14 years ago
so
um that's just some basic information
are there questions for uh
New Hampshire school boards Association
not seeing you thank you very much thank
you and I have one other card that just
arrived up on this uh Sebastian Fuentes
welcome
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the community uh my name is
Sebastian Fuentes I'm the movement
politics director for organization
called rice and democracy of New
Hampshire and I'm here to just express
my opposition to this bill uh you know I
grew up in South American Peru uh as you
know you know I I seen what a communist
terrorist organization can do to to
people in my country kill thousands of
them not just communism but also
leninism and Marxism uh so when they
talk about communism and the terrible
cause I absolutely understand it uh but
at the same time I appreciate
representative moffett's passion and I
was I'm passionate about history the
same way he is uh but at the same time
as a parent of two children in the
public education system in New Hampshire
uh communism is something the absolute
needs to be taught but also uh communism
is not killing us right now you know
what it's killing us right now at this
specific time is you know for example
white supremacy and we don't talk enough
about it you know uh I'd be more than
happy to to have a class about you know
uh media about you know Laos and Vietnam
and everything that happened in
communism but at the same time we're
going to talk about Cambodia let's talk
about Ferguson Missouri if we're going
to talk about pawpaw and Mao and Putin
and Nikita Chef let's talk about uh you
know George Floyd and you need to talk
about trade with Merlin because that's
what's killing us right now white
supremacists and we don't talk enough
about it so communism is an issue
absolutely yes but let's talk about what
is really really killing Our Generation
you know it might not be 50 years ago
like you mentioned about you know I'm 40
so I was kind of close to that but I
understand my history and I love that uh
but we're going to talk also about you
know Mr Murphy said we need to talk
about all these details like the the
siege of Saigon for example let's talk
about the seashore the Capitol Building
as well so we're going to talk about one
thing this also include the rest and
that's all I have to say thank you thank
you very much Sebastian are there would
you like taking any questions absolutely
any questions for Sebastian
not seeing it thank you very much
but I don't have any other cards on 102
up here yes representative I have not
yet filled out a card but may I take two
minutes or less to testify I'm a
co-sponsor on the bill
yeah you can but uh is it something you
could express to the committee during
executive session
um it can wait yes okay thank you
because we are right down where we have
one more bill here prior to lunch we
have to tackle here
um so what we'll do is we'll close down
this hearing right here now and we're
going to move into the next one
did we get a card up from Rector Roy
okay great okay
okay the next next bill that's up on the
docket here is HB 103 relative to school
board member qualifications and
representative Roy you're already at the
chair Welcome to our committee
I thank you chairman Ladd and members of
the committee
um honored to be before you this morning
introducing house bill 103. this bill
was brought at the request of a
constituent who is here and who will
testify after me I'm just going to give
you a quick brief introduction as to why
um this gentleman is an educator in one
of the districts in my in my district
and he wanted to run for school board
and he was prohibited by Statute because
he's an employee of an SAU he wanted to
run for
School Board in a district other than
the one he was employed in but because
of the statute he could not because it's
the same SAU
what we're proposing is that he be able
to
um run for school board in the district
other than the one he employed he's
employed in but within the same SAU and
he would have to or anyone who in this
like position would have to recuse
themselves for anything to do with the
superintendent's terms of employment
um having said that I am going to let
him make his case to you and I really
appreciate you taking the time to take a
look at it thank you thank you very much
representative any questions
thank you
I know nothing huh okay
so do we have the card from your
constituent he just there are a couple
coming up okay I've got two and for me
are we talking about Greg great
Whitmore yes okay welcome to education
yes thank you for having me
uh so very briefly what got me here
um as Miss Roy said I'm a teacher at a
public school and last year I ran for
school board at my daughter's school a
few weeks before the election I was
informed that I am ineligible uh because
my school and her school are in the same
the same SAU
um the town was not aware of this I mean
really nobody was it came as a a
complete shock to say the least
um so really what it comes down to is
the pool of individuals that's willing
to serve on a school board is already
quite limited and the RSA is written uh
really puts unnecessary restrictions on
individuals whose background in
education would be invaluable in the
role of a school board member so if we
were to look at my specific case the two
schools have nothing to do with one
another besides being in the same SAU we
do share a superintendent but there is
really nothing on a day-to-day basis
whatsoever that really involves the two
of them
um so what I'm looking for what I what I
think would be reasonable is to rewrite
a portion of the of the RSA to State
something along the lines of a person
who is a salaried employee at a school
within an SAU shall be able to serve on
the school board of a school within the
SAU with the exception of the school
with which they are employed by
and must recuse themselves from any
school board matters pertaining to the
hiring firing and disciplinary actions
involving the superintendent because
with you know I've spoken to a lot of
Educators about this just to get their
perspective and really the only issue
that could come up is they say well you
know the superintendent is technically
your boss and you would be the boss of
the superintendent if you were on the
school board that's the yeah that
certainly is the case but if you were to
put in you know a stipulation where you
know anytime a specific matter between
myself and the superintendent came up or
the school board such as you know hiring
firing or disciplinary actions if I were
to recuse myself from those actions then
that really could be the only issue
so
um you know it's it's certainly not a
unique situation I find myself in but it
is a rare situation to say the least
it's something that I'm sure would not
come up very often but you know when you
have someone that's willing and really
wants to serve on a board
um a limitation like this just seems
unnecessary
thank you very much Greg thank you uh
are there any questions for for Greg
yes representative Luna yeah um thank
you um thank you very much Mr Whitmore
for um uh for bringing this up
um
first of all I'm having a hard time
understanding how the language being
proposed here actually addresses what
your um what your what what your um what
you ran into but I'm also
not sure
about how the current statute would have
prevented
um well I could see it preventing you
from running for school board in the
same SAU but not in a not in a different
essay which is what you're you know I
I'm I'm referring to if I wanted to
serve on a board in the same SAU so
they're different schools yeah
um but I would like to serve on the
school board of a different School
within the same SAU and the current
statue clearly you know prohibits that
okay and what I'm suggesting is having a
stipulation allowing someone that would
be in my situation to serve on the
school board of a school that I don't
work for but is in the same SAU and just
with the stipulation that with you know
anything that deals specifically with
the only shared instance which is the
superintendent it's the only thing we
share right
um that if matters come up that I would
have to recuse myself so just a
follow-up for Clarity on that so it
would be not the essay you board but the
the school board itself yeah for example
a school within the essay yes
for a clarification uh representative
Roy did speak with me prior to this
meeting early this morning saying he did
have some amending language to try and
clarify uh and and state this the way
the intent okay because it's not coming
yeah that's exactly there the reads are
and that Amendment would be provided to
somebody on this committee which we
could introduce ourselves in the
executive session to
address that yes representative Roy
the amendment was sent to representative
he has it I've never met my position
before they've been this over Facebook
and the language is a result of that
match
um however we've clarified it and the
amendment was sent and it does exactly
what the constituents asked okay yeah
okay good thank you representative
represent Cornell you have a question
thank you thank you for taking my
question would you not be voting on
teacher contracts so teacher contracts
are negotiated just within the schools
themselves so my you know my high school
would have nothing to do with my
daughter's school as far as teacher
contracts so the follow-up so the SAU
doesn't vote on all teacher contracts
um
so it would not be an SAU vote it would
be an individual School Board vote
okay thank you representative Woodcock
yes thank you Mr and this is probably
more for president cordelli
um in the the amendment which we don't
see which we don't have uh I'm I'm
concerned on this particular bill in
lines fourth four and five where it
deals with Municipal budget committees
and and the affiliation with uh that and
I was just wondering if that information
if that line is taken off of the
amendment because I know in many seus as
in ours required the Schoolboy members
around the municipal budget committee
thank you um yeah I had this discussion
with representative Roy uh yesterday
um he uh submitted
um for drafting an amendment and I
believe have sent it to me I haven't had
a chance to read it yet however
okay so Master chair then so what we
want to do is that we recognize is going
to this doesn't say what is the intent
of you know and there may be some
conflicts with other areas I think we
got to address that during the executive
session time I think everybody's
agreeing there's it needs to be cleaned
up okay so my only question of the show
is that in the so knowing here except
representative Roy couldn't answer that
question is could you answer that
question if you wrote the amendment
yeah yeah that portion is still in there
representative but it doesn't conflict
with the statute that requires a member
this says at large so that's what that
means of someone you wouldn't have
several of them on here 100
representative order selectman and the
one from the school board that's already
there this would be an additional so you
wouldn't be able to run for
um that large position of the medicinal
budget community and the school board if
you follow what I mean my followers to
choose I read it here okay thank you
thank you Mr chairman yeah and as soon
as we get that Amendment and so we can
start working on it prior to
it would be helpful are there any other
questions
of Greg yes representative cascadden
thank you Mr chair be quick
um just for clarification on the
terminologies
the way that I'm interpreting your
request is that
if schools are in different towns yes
and they may be one SAU but the towns
operate under their own school boards
that's where you're going so the
language may be clarified in the
amendment because a municipality would
not have multiple towns but might have
multiple schools it is very difficult to
get the wording right enough thank you
that's a good point yeah
further questions
thank you very much thank you
um let's see on 103 uh bear Christina
school boards Association
good morning members of the committee uh
thank you chairman lad bear Christina
from the New Hampshire school boards
Association I want to thank
representative Roy for clarifying that
an amendment may be coming the testimony
both by representative Roy and uh the
the other individual
um caught me off guard to be quite
honest with you seemed very different
than what I thought it was going to be
based on on the language of the bill and
I see everybody sort of nodding and
whatnot so
um if I could respectfully maybe just
ask a favor that before I spend time
dealing with this which is a completely
the the bill in front of us is
completely different than what I thought
it was going to be based on the
testimony that we heard if I could have
an opportunity to perhaps address the
committee if and when the the revised
Bill comes out I know that may be during
executive session and you don't
necessarily take testimony during
executive session but my testimony right
now I'm not prepared to talk about what
may be coming out because I thought this
was I thought this was truck
in reading this bill I thought it was
restricting who could run for school
board I thought it was restricting
um family members
um uh from working in the schools if
they if they if they if they had a
spouse or a child that was on the school
board so I'm I'm a little confused which
is very not the best way to get my first
testimony before I had the same
impression and understanding as you just
presented to us and when we do this
working with this amendment you've
helped us out with manifest education
hardship and we looked at your support
to work with you in trying to clean this
up thank you very much Mr chair you're
welcome
questions for yeah it's real real really
question to the chair and um and um uh
attorney Christina uh uh also when when
considering the amendment for this and
the language for the uh considering the
the potential intersection with RSA 32
which is the municipal budget committee
I can address that now if that's all
right
um the provision about prohibited from
being a member at large on the municipal
budget committee that's already in
current law RSA 32 colon 15 sub
paragraph
um five Roman numeral five no selectman
Town manager member of the school board
Village District commissioner full-time
employee part-time Department had so on
and so forth none of those Shall Serve
as a member at large of a municipal
budget committee under 32. so if that
provision is already covered in law
thank you
yes represent Damon I think this is
actually a question for you chairman is
there ever a hearing on an amendment
when it sounds like the amendment will
be a considerably different Bill than
what we have in front of us
yes if the amendment is totally
different than the bill but the decision
would be have to you know be made is
this amendment non-germaine to uh the
bill that we're discussing I don't think
what we're discussing right now is
really non-germaine it's uh we just have
I think a wording problem and linkage
with other statutes and that we can
clean all this stuff up
and hopefully we can great thank you for
the clarification yeah
so any other questions for Mr Christina
thank you very much
do we have any more cards on this yes uh
Brian
Hawkins Nea New Hampshire
thank you Mr chairman I think I'll be
even shorter than uh Mr Christina uh I
originally checked off opposition to
this bill but having heard the intent
um you know I I I scratched that off
um and so uh what not having the
amendment I would the only thing I would
just offer is that uh whatever the
committee arrives at that it it we're
not going in uh a more restrictive uh
qualifications for uh than
um and certainly you know
I have no problem with what the what the
intent that sounds like of the bill is
so I'll just I'll just leave it when we
get all this squared away and you've
worked with us in the code of ethics and
all that we'd be glad to work with you
also great thank you
it's a matter of timing right now I
think we can put together just a group
of people to work on that so we'll do
something on that end so we can get
going on it because I think we know
where we want to go it's just we got
Awards method
instead of running out the door I think
you're off the hook representative Roy
you've been using Facebook
Okay are there any other uh questions or
people like to testify on the on this
intent
so thank you very much we're going to
close this hearing
and it's about a quarter of right now
and I think where we are
we're at lunch
yes it's the best part of the day you
know or maybe a German is but we're
trying to reconvene Mr chair we we can
be in at one o'clock to do HP 168. thank
you yep
so we're we're reconvening at one
o'clock thank you
thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee members uh for the record
Glenn cordelli uh representing uh tuft
and Borough Wolfeboro and Ossipee in the
beautiful Lakes Region
um this is a pretty simple Bill uh just
adjusts the requirement for Surety bonds
uh to protect student tuitions
um for students going to a career School
and the reason I'm happy to sponsor this
is because I had involvement in a
situation with a career School
um several years ago well 10 12 years
ago our County built a new nursing home
we still have and still to this day have
the old Nursing Home in place
uh the old nursing home
um has a beautiful
well equipped kitchen and a large dining
room that's
doing nothing right now
um several years ago a a group
had the idea to form a Culinary Academy
came to the county to talk about use of
the space and worked out Arrangements
but
there are procedures you have to go
through to start a career School a
Career Academy and this is part of it
um
so what happened is that they ran into
problems with the process and
um as local representative they reached
out to me
and I got involved and had multiple
meetings with the Department of
Education
Mr Appleby's predecessor Dr McCabe who
was in charge of queer schools back then
um the problem was with the amount of
the surety bond that was being required
of them
um I forget the exact dollars involved
but it was a a very substantial monthly
amount
uh to pay for the surety bond well
beyond their means
um to to do to get donors to help them
on a monthly basis with uh funding of
the surety bond
um
so long story short it
um finally uh got stalled
um they probably were not going to be
able to go forward but uh then
unfortunately the um
uh one of the principals who was a
career CTE a culinary instructor who was
the lead
instructor for this Culinary Academy uh
uh took ill and the group dissolved um
just an interesting note that during the
past general election a local Democrat
State Rep candidate
um who had conversation with turned out
that um that Chef was her father
so we had very nice conversations she
didn't realize that I was the person who
had been trying to help them but
I am well aware of the problems in
trying to get started a career School in
this case a Culinary Academy and
would very much like to see
a reasonable requirements for the surety
bond both to cover the students but also
to allow the Career Academy get started
the more we can do you know I come from
the Lakes Region right below the White
Mountains hospitality is huge in our
area a Culinary Academy would have been
fantastic to help Supply people to those
restaurants and clubs in in the area
unfortunately it didn't happen but you
know anything we can do to make it more
accessible to people to start a career
Academy and provide opportunities
I think the better we all will be
in terms of the exact
the 10 percent
um in the bill and so forth
um I think Mr Appleby can better address
that than I but I wanted to present this
bill because of uh my personal
involvement with a career School
so thank you thank you very much
uh good afternoon
uh we'll find Lakes Region uh I
understand clearly Glenn about the
community school and the county school
and the college school my concern is
um not that particular School my concern
is if I recall uh the intent of this
bill was to be able to provide
reimbursement for a lot of those quick
startup career schools that come and go
and the students that participate from
20 to 80 get their tuition back at the
school was bankrupt that goes belly up
and I'm concerned looking at the change
to the percentage of the annual growth
of projected tuition that that may not
cover if the school starts up and goes
out at midnight and packs the cars and
goes away
so is it that's my concern how what's
your take on that as regards this bill
I I think that that is a reasonable
question to ask and I think Mr Appleby
um will probably be able to address that
better than I in terms of his experience
with startup career academies
um and the whole process and uh the
protections for students okay thank you
thank you Mr chair you're welcome uh yes
representative uh
I know it's afternoon thank you Mr chair
we need more of that coffee here we're
doing nothing I'll share it with you uh
just so for some clarification because
I'm I'm familiar with CTE centers so are
you talking about adding a program to a
current career in technical Ed Regional
Center that we have in the state no I'm
sorry if I was confusing that um the
principal who was involved in the
program was a former CTE culinary
instructor and he and a couple of other
people were trying to start a career
School a new Culinary Academy outside of
CTE nothing to do with CTE so something
in a private room correct whereas if
that culinary program it could work in a
partnership with the Local District to
be a culinary arts program within their
Korean technical Regional session we
talked about that that CTE students upon
graduation could come and get further
education at The Culinary Academy before
moving on to a local establishment and
if it was a partnership with the
regional center would it not then be
covered under endemic indemnification
of that program I'll leave that to Mr
Appleby okay thank you
any further questions for representative
cordelli
uh Steve Mr Appleby uh
do you have a pink card done or not okay
after don't worry about it right now
this moment yeah
um
perhaps what you could do Steve is
explain a little bit about these
post-secondary career schools because I
know that's your bailiwick over there
with certification yep um good afternoon
everyone um thank you for your time this
afternoon for the record my name is
Stephen Appleby I am the director of
educator support in higher education at
the department of Ed one of the programs
I oversee is the chair alluded to is the
licensing of post-secondary career
schools just by way of history as
representative cordelli mentioned some
history with this issue I was an owner
at one time of a licensed Career School
in our state so my involvement with
Career School licensing statutes and
administrative rules goes back about 23
years 24 years
there was a change so a little bit of
explanation post-secondary career
schools the key words there are
post-secondary right these are schools
that are started that are geared towards
folks who have completed high school and
they may be looking for vocational
training of some sort or computer
training maybe they want to work in an
office they need Microsoft Office
training or LNA training outside it so
you know they're they're closest if you
want to think about equivalence they're
closest to Nature typically to our
community colleges
um
but again they also fulfill niches so we
have a school in Manchester that teaches
individuals how to be professional dog
groomers
so we have that and we run the gamut we
have an HVAC school we have a heavy
equipment operator school and they I'm
sorry this is a little bit in the way
yeah
um so these schools fulfill it you know
training for a number of professions
um but but that fall outside they're
typically not accredited and they are
typically for-profit although they're
exceptions to both of those statements
um so The Surety and then vacation was
put in place many many years ago to
protect students from exactly the type
of concern that a school closes
precipitously students have paid tuition
and because the school is a
tuition-based school they of course
can't pay it back because they've gone
bankrupt we
in 2021 in the fall of 2021 we had our
largest licensed career post-secondary
career School in the State closed
precipitously
um and that school had a bond and that
bond to date has reimbursed about two
hundred and four thousand dollars in
tuition to its students
I would note that that is less than 10
percent of its annual adjusted gross
tuition it's more in the order of about
seven percent and this was our largest
school prior to that closure in 2021 the
last time we had to exercise a bond was
I believe 2015 so these are not common
events
um in my 20 to 23 years gosh I don't
want to date myself
um I I can think of four instances where
we've had to collect on a bond that I'm
aware of of course for a good part of
that time I was on the other side of the
table
but it's a small community most of us
know each other most schools know each
other we used to have a career School
Association that I helped co-found many
years ago and
um again with an idea of strengthening
the industry and keeping folks who
aren't serious out of the industry
because it hurts everyone right when a
one school closes it hurts all the other
schools regardless of what they teach so
that's a little bit of background
questions on background
great
um prior to 2018 the standard that we
had for many many years was that a
school would would get up obtain a bond
for 10 percent of their annual tuition
and
um that worked well for licensure
purposes because schools could go to a
bond company point to the RSA say here's
my tax return or here's my first year
business projection and it here's the
statute says 10 of that so if my first
year projection is 250 000 in tuition
then I need a bond for twenty five
thousand dollars the bond companies it
was clean for them they understood it
they could write that Bond since the
change in 2018
the way the change was to move to more
of an ongoing what your potential
liability is in any given year at any
given time the bond companies have
struggled to write bonds and
subsequently have charged schools more
to obtain those bonds because it's not
as clean it's harder for the schools to
to talk about liability throughout the
year because it may change depending on
number of students they have as programs
start and programs and that number goes
up and down the liability likewise where
that those students on a particular
program
the school that I mentioned that closed
in 2021 we had a number of students who
were 95 completed with their program
and the liability of undelivered
training at that point was very very
small and in fact was taught out by
another school so
um in that instance the liability was
very very small and the industry stepped
up and covered for that school but based
on the current statute the school had to
carry a bond for that full tuition so
this is in in the proposed change is a
reaction to comments from school owners
around the state that the 10 percent was
much easier our bond company understood
it and frankly it cost us less to
maintain that Bond than the current
system so
okay
so are you willing to take any questions
from the committee here are there any
questions for Mr Appleby representative
luno okay in fact thanks very much Mr
chair and thank you very much
um Steve Appleby for uh joining us this
afternoon and taking taking some
questions what are um what are other
states doing with respect to um um
post-secondary career
um again schools so um it really runs
the gamut from a small percentage to
full year so if your Revenue was one
million dollars last year you need to
carry a bond for one million dollars to
potentially
um requiring other schools to do
teachouts and having teachout agreements
in place with other schools
so it really kind of runs the gamut yes
thanks Mr chair
um I'm I'm intrigued by the the teachout
um Clauses that's something that uh that
you think um if if we were to move
forward in this direction that having a
a teachout requirement might be a good
um um I think uh frankly
um the states that were that rely on
teachouts are states like Pennsylvania
that have hundreds and hundreds of these
schools we have less than 60.
so the challenge would be that for
example the dog grooming school that I
mentioned
they're it
so who would do the teach out
for them
so if we made a requirement that they
needed to have a teachout plan in place
with a competitor they don't have a
competitor so does that mean they would
have to close or a new school couldn't
open because there was no competitor so
that that's so the states that do
teachouts tend to be the largest states
so and so so since you since you sort of
posed a question back to me on on that
which is a little unusual
um during hearing but uh but that's all
right that's my style on this
conversation the beginning of the season
so uh yeah
but but but I would I would I would I
would suggest though that if the dog
grooming school was was closing down
that they would also be um there would
be an availability then of um of
teaching staff who were uh and and
instructional space that another school
might be able to continue to operate to
fulfill the um you know the contracts
that they've made with that the former
school had with their students and that
that another school might be able to
pick up using those those resources so
just by virtue of the fact that we've
only got about 60-ish schools as opposed
to you know thousands of ish schools uh
like Pennsylvania that that there may be
be a solution if if we're trying to do
something that is favorable to uh to
operating these schools that we also do
something in the same construction
that's favorable to the students
completing their their program
okay uh with representative Woodcock you
are next thank you Sharon
um
Davis Appleby I can see the church
yeah much much better we're going to
just move your chair so you don't have
to worry about it I think it was nobody
um my question is I understand the the
the the the rationale for this uh your
explanation Glenn's explanation clearly
uh
but the intent if I understand the
original Law to make sure the students
are not the one that were footing the
loss
so in this bill
is the change in the best interest of
the students for the change or in the
best interest of the for-profit owner
thank you for the question
um
I think both
I think both because if
it is more of a financial burden on our
schools to carry a bond that raises
tuition
um so
and it raises the bar as representative
cordelli mentioned to even start a
school
so I
to me it it benefits both sides it it's
certainly clearer that it benefits a
career School owner
but I think it has a knock-on effect to
their students or prospective students
in the case of an institution trying to
open
thank you thank you Mr chairman you're
welcome representative Tanner
thank you Mr chair I actually have two
questions one was representative
cordelli talked about payments ongoing
payments and is it a one one time a year
payment to an insurance company I assume
there are insurance companies that hold
these or is it an ongoing monthly
payment that the school has to come up
with thank you
um for the question that that would be
up to the school and its insurance
company similar to when you buy car
insurance you can pay annually you can
pay monthly okay and monthly cost you a
little more each month and you're really
just financing that so it really depends
on the school and and the insurance
company and my second question is is
there does this apply to all career
schools that are trying to get
um startup that they have to get a
license uh and be under regulations or
is there a threshold on for example
Susie Jones who decides that she wants
to teach two dog walkers
um does she have to get a license or is
there a threshold on yearly tuition
gross tuition or even numbers of
students in the academy great question
thank you so I I'll point out first of
all these are vocational schools not
avocational schools so the person who
decides they're going to teach kids how
to play the piano out of their home this
doesn't cover those individuals that's
avocational
but the person who opens a school to
teach individuals how to be piano
teachers as a profession that's
vocational so those will be covered so
that a person T you know dog walking
that would not typically be covered
unless they're teaching people how to
start businesses to be dog walkers or
something right
um but you know the the threshold I
believe
um so statutory change last year is 100
000 a year in annual revenue below that
they do not need a license that was a
new statute
um but so it all depends when a new
school comes to the Department
they present A business plan and that
business plan has a revenue projection
that Revenue projection is a hundred
thousand dollars in their first year
then we require them to get a bond if it
is below that then we do not require but
uh one of they have to check back in
with us after a year to see have they
gone above it and it is incumbent upon
them to tell us if they're above a
hundred thousand dollars then their
exclusion expired that is no longer
valid and they have to apply for a
license
thank you further questions of Steve
Appleby
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you we have another bill coming up a
little later here on on well I see Kathy
province is already here so you might
want to hang around if you have a moment
or two
um are there any other people who want
to testify on on this bill 168
not seeing any so we'll close this
hearing
okay and we'll roll into HP 155
this bill is relative to
um uh see 150 yeah relative to division
of educator support in a higher
education and relative to Surety
indemnification for private
post-secondary career schools somewhat
the same but a little bit different
representative moffatt
making the show is waiting for you to
invite me
oh you found your way to the party or
the table without having to be invited
didn't you be familiar with it been here
before uh to include even today thank
you uh again Mr chair and members for
the record uh I am still uh Mike Moffett
uh Merrimack for
beautiful towns of Canterbury in Loudon
um in this uh HP 155 is an act relative
to the division of educated support in
higher education and relative to Surety
indemnification for private
post-secondary career schools
Surety indemnification
um I kind of would rather talk about
communism again but let's uh let's get
into this uh
charity indemnification so uh you all
have a copy of uh HP 155 so Indemnity is
the backbone of many Surety Bonds in
short
uh in Indemnity compels a party to
compensate another party for cause
and the surety bond involves the obligee
having the legal right to collect from
The Surety if the principal
of the blind fails to uphold their end
of the bond arrangements or whatever
agreements that they uh agreed upon
so hb155 modifies some statutory
language concerning uh Doe's division of
educator support in higher education
this would be as I'm sure you all know
RSA 21-n colon 8-a Roman numeral two
so they have it on so you can see the
changes in the uh in the measure that
you should have in front of you so on
page one line 15 you'll see uh it
removes section seven
which involves one member of the higher
education commission to be appointed by
the governor and Council as a
representative
from a for-profit calls University
that's not a member of the New Hampshire
college and university Council
and some of the thinking here being that
a that a private
for profit Institution
um there might be some issues that being
regulated by a competing
uh Public School Commission
on page two line eight
you will see the subsection 4
is also removed with regard to applying
for Grants
Etc
some some of the thinking here being
that it is uh it could be unwieldy for a
commission to apply for Grant a
commission to apply for Grants as
opposed to an institution applying for
Grants it's it's a little different
on page three
lines three through seven you see
there's more language changes and
crossouts some of the thinking here
being that the current Bond requirement
is potential is potentially daunting and
potentially overwhelming
um which could make it unnecessarily for
fatal
to an institution obligated to secure a
blind sufficient to reimburse the
tuition for a quote any service contract
unquote
so when you see something that says any
service uh that kind of also means every
service contract so the new proposed
language I think is a is a little more
realistic and a little more manageable
also on page three lines 19 through 21
you'll see the new language that
quantifies the amount in question for an
irrevocable letter of credit
but you see it it says uh now it says at
least
uh changing it to be equal to at least
10 percent of the annual gross tuition
for the current Academic Year as opposed
to Simply being quote determined by the
commission
so the language of something just being
quote unquote determined by the
commission is a little uh a lot elastic
to be to be sure
um is the way the state is where the
statute currently reads the commission
could you know theoretically uh
determine almost any amount so this uh
limits and quantifies that this is where
we get the uh
the 10 figure
and so that takes us through all the
language changes in
I would say 21-n colon 8 dash a Roman
numeral two
and thank you for your attention I'd be
happy to try to answer any questions I
know we have some other experts here
um and try to take any questions after
pointing out that I am a sports writer
as opposed to an attorney or an
accountant
okay thank you very much are there any
questions for
representative moffatt representative
luno
thank you very much Mr chair welcome
again uh representative moffatt
um going to um
page two
line eight where um where from the um
the higher education Commission
you've removed apply for accept expense
state federal or other grants how's that
being used right now
thank you for the question
representative luno
um
it in all candor
this is a measure I was asked to help
Shepherd through so I'm not using
telephone homework on it
um and
how's it been used now I honestly if I
can make a note of it if you want to
shoot me an email I'm very good at
tracking down answers and I I honestly
don't have a good answer as to how
that's currently being used so did some
did this language come from the
Department
um I can't tell you right this minute
the the folks who uh asked me to help
with this or who uh made the recommended
changes I just looked at them and I said
I try to help and and uh is there going
to be uh is
um so question for the chair is there
going to be somebody from the Department
that can talk about how
yeah
I I couldn't I can't I can't wait
because he's right behind me okay great
great no thanks thanks I'll save it for
for um Steve thanks sure and of course
uh as soon as we leave here today you
you folks as I said this morning I'll
own this measure and and uh and and
it'll be yours
thank you for the questions for
representative moffatt not seeing any
thank you very much thank you
okay
do we have other pink cards here Steve
you have some Kathy are you here for
this bill
do you need one you just hear it here
okay
represent now represent stigma Appleby
good afternoon again for the record
Steve Appley
director of educator support and higher
education at the New Hampshire
Department of Ed
um
not recovering the ground of The Surety
medication because that's also captured
in previous Bill the language
for example beginning
um line 10
where we added designee and you'll see a
number of changes after that to the
higher education commission
this work proposal was completed in
conjunction with the university system
as well as the New Hampshire College
University Council to kind of clean up
the membership of the higher education
Commission
some of you may be aware being on this
body that you need a quorum to hold a
meeting well one of the things that the
higher education commission which is a
rule-making body struggles with
sometimes is having a quorum and this
bill cleans up some of those kind of
self-inflicted wounds if you will so for
example line 15 we have not had a
for-profit college in our state in five
years there are currently none so that
is a seat that has sat open for five
years on the higher education Commission
um likewise if we go up a little bit to
10 lines 10 and 11 where we add a
designee
those are instances where rarely do we
get
um
a Chancellor to necessarily Chancellor
show up presidents of college is not as
much and we currently have a situation
where the chancellor of the University
system is also the president of a campus
so that individual is named twice in
statute but can only fill one scene so
if that individual doesn't show up we
have two empty seats towards act warm so
the idea behind these changes is to
clean up the language recognize the
current reality of our higher education
community and quite honestly facilitate
us holding regular higher education
meetings
so that's the background happy to answer
questions thank you
other yes representative luno thank you
very much Mr chair so um so the my
question to you Mr Appleby is with
respect to how the um the uh make sure I
get the term right the higher education
commission
um
um exercises it's um
responsibility on page two line eight to
accept uh I'm sorry to apply for accept
and expend state federal and other
grants
thank you
I I did not ask for that script I'm not
sure where that came from but I can tell
you that
um prior to being in my current role I
served in the higher education
commission for 10 years and I never
saw us apply for except a grant at the
commission level
so I suspect it's just again recognize
the reality that the commission doesn't
do that
um you know follow-up on yes on that
um
I I I I appreciate the um the fact that
maybe we we the the the prime sponsor
and and your testimony is is it's it's
not a definitive know the commission
doesn't do that and it's never done that
um
um but I I think before we go about
eliminating something like that we'd
want to make sure that
um I mean I I guess that you know would
it be possible for you to produce a um a
report on what grants the commission has
applied for and you know what funds it
has expended over the last decade just
so that we can make sure that that
um
an organ a non-profit organization in
the state is all of a sudden
um losing its um it's I mean I'm you
know and there's lots of non-profit
organizations in the state is that that
it's losing its um
um you know
um you know funding
I happy to produce a report I was named
to the higher ed Commission in 2007 and
when I came to the department in 2018
resigned my position on the commission
uh so from 2007 forward
I'm happy to put that in writing yeah
if you can run a report from whatever
the you know yeah yeah but yeah um no I
I understand I suspect as well the way
that that's written may be an artifact
of potentially decades ago when the
commission was set up okay I mean the
commission goes back to the 1960s it
used to be the post-secondary education
commission and then it became the IRA
commission
um
so I again I don't know where the
language came from the strikethrough but
I'm happy to just want to make sure
we've got a clean definitive answer that
we're not you know that there's nothing
unintentional uh happening from this
okay yeah I think we need to go back you
know remember Ed McKay yeah
but it dates back to him
but okay uh any further questions uh Mr
Appleby
thank you very much okay thank you
everyone
uh okay are there any other pink slips
here we have in 155
.
um
I use my mic
so I noticed that
wording in the two bills that we've that
you've just testified on is slightly
different one is equal to at least 10
percent of the annual gross tuition in
the year the bond is secured and the
other one is equal to at least 10
percent of the annual burst tuition for
the current Academic Year
and my question is is one preferable to
the other and if we pass both of them
are they going to conflict or
I mean we got to deal with these two
bills right and so how do we deal with
them that I guess what is your
recommendation
thank you
thank you for the question
um I would defer to the language of
um hb155
for uh for the academic year because
we're trying to protect the students in
the current Academic Year so thank you
very much thank you
thank you
yes represent Cornell Thank you isn't
sonua a for-profit college
no no Southern Hampshire University is a
not-for-profit institution okay our last
um for-profit institution I don't know
who closed First Mount Washington
College or Daniel Webster college but
before the both of those those are our
last two and they were both for-profit
as they were bought by out of state
for-profit institutions
foreign
okay further questions thank you very
much again
it's hard to believe that dartmouth's
not for profit huh
all right
um
no more pink hearts than that so we're
gonna close that hearing
two o'clock
okay we have about a 15 minute break
here the other one's scheduled to start
at two o'clock yeah so we're gonna have
to hang loose here for 15 minutes
boy I thought snooze was for profit
and thank you for having me I miss you
guys
so my name is representative Deb Hobson
and I represent Rockingham County
District 14. so I was asked to bring
this measure uh by one of my
constituents and unfortunately they
couldn't join me today
um so I'm hoping that this measure will
be a simple change to an existing
statute but make a profound difference
in the lives of students across New
Hampshire changing the term encourage in
RSA 189 colon 11-c to require
um so how many times have you all been
surprised by a youngster that um can't
read a greeting card from their
grandmother or a note from a manager and
so I as I was doing some research on
this bill I was really surprised to
learn how much cursive handwriting helps
all kinds of learning disabilities
it's in essence like learning a new
language
and uh the PBS news hour I will hand out
this testimony at the conclusion of my
speaking PBS NewsHour interviewed a
ninth grade student that was diagnosed
with dyslexia after struggling for 10
years at school cursive writing
exercises may have helped this student
by integrating the hand-eye coordination
and fine motor skills functional MRIs
show us show a stronger Association for
learning and memory when hands are
involved another quote from Minds in
motion a state that cursive writing
creates neural Pathways required to
stimulate brain activity for language
fluency Envision motor control needed
for cognitive develop reading Sports and
socialization
for example taking notes helps students
facilitate deeper and more critical
thinking and kids assimilate the content
and remember the content better and I
can attest because that process works
for me
Psychology today October 2020 indicates
that there is accumulating evidence that
not learning cursive handwriting May
hinder the brain's Optimum potential to
learn and remember
a study out of Norway
used high density EEG to monitor the
brain's electrical activity when
students use keyboards cursive writing
and drawing visual visually presented
Works using a digital pen or traditional
pen paper and pencil data analysis shows
that cursive handwriting primed the
brain for learning by synchronizing
brain waves and stimulating more
Electric electrical activity in the
brain's parietal lobe and central region
this provides the brain with optimal
conditions for learning cursive writing
activates a unique
reading circuit in the brain so the
parietal lobe that gets stimulated with
cursive writing interprets visual
information retains short-term memory
senses temperature changes through touch
helps control language mathematical
problem solving skills these seem to be
really helpful with some of the learning
loss that our students have encountered
one scientist said that pen and paper
gives the brain more hooks in quotes to
hang on to your memory your memories
onto a lot of senses are activated by
pressing the paper the pen onto the
paper seeing letters you write and
hearing the sound you make while writing
these sense experiences create contact
between different parts of the brain and
open the brain up for learning the
School Board Association and the
superintendents Association this morning
testified that this might be considered
curriculum bill but this measure is
already in statute and is simply a
change from encourage to require
districts that are that are already
providing this program I would imagine
they need not change their practices
but encourage versus require means that
some students might be getting this
instruction and some might not
um so that is the testimony I have and I
don't know if there's any questions I'll
try to answer them thank you very much
representative Hobson represent Lucas
thank you thank you
um I was talking to some people this
morning and the other day who insisted
that all these things are being taught
to all of our students both the cursive
writing and the math are being taught to
all of our students today and so I'm
asking do you have any examples or do
you know of cases where that's not being
done
uh well I do have personal experience
um with students that are not
um sorry not doing uh not able to read
cursive but I I do not know in my own
school if that's being taught I think
some other people are going to testify
and they may have some evidence
further question represent woodcock
thank you Mr chairman uh welcome back
thank you good to see you
um
um as you can see I still use it nobody
can read it uh sometimes they can't read
an hour later uh so the Reinhardt method
is not working well for me I think we
can help you yeah thank you appreciate
that
um but beyond those concerned about the
the multiplication tables uh has this
been aligned with any of the current
elementary school curriculums have we
talked the elementary school curriculum
committees as it involved in the the the
uh doe content piece for elementary
schools I'm thinking I I can't imagine
that the multiplication tables aren't
pot and parcel uh uh what the youngsters
do coming up as part of the elementary
math
I think the part that
concerning the fact that the requirement
of the memorization of that and what if
that's the difference I just I don't
know if you've talked it I thought it
was being done uh and I just didn't know
if you had a chance to in this bill to
talk to doe or Elementary theology
Association yeah um thank you for the
question and I did speak with
commissioner edelblue he has provided
technical advisories on math facts I was
not able to get to that before testimony
today
um
so I I don't really have
I guess concrete evidence of the
multiplication tables but they're in the
same statute so that's why it's we're
being talked about today okay and one of
the maybe one of the following and just
um back to the question I made uh
uh
not the curse of itself
but the fact that if we integrate once
again that should be a local piece but
if we do that it clearly is going to be
an identifiable cost of that and that
youngsters now don't have pencils and
paper and crayons we have the backpack
movements before we start every year
yeah you can't go to school and find
these types of things for kids like we
used to in our day so it's going to be
uh I'm not going to say it's
extraordinary no idea but the clearly is
going to be a cost for Schools starting
to which they probably should have been
doing all along they're providing
writing supplies for youngsters as they
go through the system as a pot and
parcel of this carefus piece so it would
be some some additional cost there okay
I'm concerned it's not there now there's
no paper so is that a question I'm sorry
yes got a question so have you looked
into that is in terms of one of the
extenuating circumstances of putting
cursive into the requirement
uh you know I I thought about that I
can't say that um
I thought the fiscal impact would be
significant
um
pretty sure schools have pencils and
papers and crayons but
um I think that's probably something
that can be teased out in this committee
thank you thank you
yeah representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for presenting this bill
you're preaching to the choir
um my concern is I had a similar concern
this morning with the communism bill
um
instruction a certain vagueness to
provide instruction at least that one
said something about 60 Minutes there
was some attainable
goal here it seems so vague that
you know a teacher could be like not
really in agreement that this is
something and then five minutes be like
oh we talked about cursive yeah you know
what I mean so that was just a concern I
wanted to bring up and I didn't know if
you had any comments on clarifying this
yeah so I guess my uh thank you for the
question and I guess my answer would be
um as a state member or from the state's
perspective
requiring it to be taught the local
control piece would allow the teachers
and the administrators to decide
what program to use how to do it so I
don't know that we're just saying that
it's an important piece and that it
should be required
so the local control piece can stay
right where it is as far as you know
again we can talk about in committee how
to what that looks like
I don't know if that answers your
question or not sorry if we'll go to
this side uh represent Luna
thank you Mr chair and thank you very
much representative Hobson for uh for
joining us today
um you know we've uh I think a lot of us
obviously have been on school boards and
and we've had you know kids our own kids
in in public schools and uh and uh and
so you know we've we've we've conducted
ourselves in a variety of different
capacities either as parents of students
or school board members or
um or you know State reps being in our
communities talking with constituents
and for sure we've all heard uh from a
lot of people about
um uh our schools and what we should be
doing and concerns
um and there's obviously you know we're
going to be getting a pile of bills like
this like we had last year
regarding a lot of this stuff you know a
lot of it will have to do with um you
know uh you know diversity Equity
inclusion a lot of it has to do with
teaching credentials a lot of it has to
do with a lot of other things but where
in your mind does cursive
um fit in this um you know uh I guess
scope of uh of you know things that
you've heard from from people in terms
of what what schools should be doing
uh well like I said I'm bringing this
forward on behalf of a constituent I
have I hear it constantly that schools
should be doing this school should be
doing that
um so the statute exists I think whoever
put it there thinks that it's an
important piece
um and I think that if we can help
offset some struggles for kids
um I think that's a good thing
um trying to remember the other parts of
your question is this important
um anything that can
make an experience for children happier
at school and help them in their
learning I think is worthwhile
so so follow up on that yes
um would it um so so you know what's in
the statute is very different than
what's what you've proposed here because
what you're proposing is changing a
statute that is advisory and turning it
into a mandate
um but to the point that that you make
and I have no reason to um to to
um to to take exception to this for
example I think you use the um an
example of a student with dyslexia
um made you know see some some
improvement uh with with cursive uh but
would that prohibit a um a student's IEP
from from having cursive in there even
though not every student in the in the
school would be learning cursive
oh I don't think I understand your
question uh reply now so could could the
could the could the student with
dyslexia have in their individualized
educational program
um a um uh a requirement on the on the
school to um to help instruct that
student in cursive without requiring the
school to instruct every student in
cursive
uh you know what I probably am not
qualified to answer that question
um there is someone that's testifying
um after me that probably would be
better suited we'll take it upside great
okay thanks
for the questions
representative Tanner
thank you and thank you representative
Hobson and it's good to see you back you
too um
would you be uh willing to extend this
through an amendment to uh apply to
Charter Schools as well
um
well charter schools are public schools
but they're not they don't follow any of
the regulations unless specifically
stated in the regulation okay uh
I I don't know
um I don't see why that would be a
detraction I think it would if it helps
one I think it would help them all
further questions
yes represent dry thank you Mr chairman
uh representative Hobson I just had a
quick question about this letter from
it's not signed yeah I'm sorry about
that I was having some trouble getting
it printed that was from uh a teacher
that um that I had interviewed so my
question is she mentions
concerning math that there are some
students that need different approaches
to multiplication yeah so I'm wondering
how they get incorporated into something
that's requiring multiplication tables
if they need a different approach well
um thank you for the question and like I
mentioned there is some guidance from
the commissioner and I think that's
probably something that can be teased
out in the bill I mean in committee
further questions
yes representative Woodcock even though
I have two one for you and one for
representative I'll start with you since
you are the chairman
um Rick was there a point in time when
cursor was a required part of the
curriculum way back you know well I I
can tell you as my experience because I
started out as a fourth grade teacher
and cursive was taught through the
spelling program we had and you wrote
and we at the same time you got phonics
out of it and you got other uh skills
Associated so you were doing more than
one thing at a time right my training on
becoming a teacher was at Orono
University of Maine yes sir and I came
back for a certification or as a special
student just become because my first
degree was in geography and urban
renewal and so I came back as a special
teacher in elementary took another 30
hours
penmanship was a required course at that
time as an elementary teacher
and so I learned to use the zaner
blowzer method some are using the Palmer
method at the time but
um it was something that I was required
I remember that class well because the
teacher at Orono said young man you come
up and you write on the board and I did
but I know what she was doing she was
going to grade me based upon what I did
then and what I did at the end of the
course so of course you you know being a
wise guy out of the military I just put
anything on the board but it's important
to believe that you can't believe that
but I I I can tell you yes it was part
of the required areas of study
at the winter Winthrop Elementary School
in Winthrop Maine New Hampshire
I did not live I was brought up in
Canada and then to Maine so okay um but
all the classes throughout you know and
of course then we didn't have we had
type writers right right and so reports
were handed in in cursive at the time
okay thanks for the question thank you I
had one for rubbing the popson
um would you be amenable to splitting
these between mathematics and cursive
make it two bills
make an amendment that has two bills but
I see that I see the mathematics uh and
the requirement for multiplication and
the memorization and those as a totally
different uh Bill uh and clearly totally
different way to my support I thought
the mice have one means anything for one
person but I just think together they
have less chance they do it divided so
if you maybe consider that
oh yeah thank you for the question and
sure
just as a note on that uh this is no
longer representative Hobson's bill this
is our bill so you have the opportunity
to do that if you so desire to you know
amend or scratch delete out and then
keep part or modify one way or the other
that's well I see she has two
significant uh uh co-sponsors here on
the bill in the room they could probably
do it much better than I oh good
you
okay if there are no further questions
of reps and Hobbs and we have other
people that are here Dr Michael uh
Gendry
g-e-n-d-r-e
thank you
uh you have to press the button on the
red button you know or yeah
you just push down you'll see it come on
yes my name is Michael Gendry I live in
Northampton I'm actually on the school
board in Northampton I've taught
Philosophy for about 35 years in
Massachusetts
I can tell you I actually came to
testify on the on the writing on the
cursive part not so much on the
multiplication table so I appreciate
your your suggestion to keep something
going
um it's my it's been my experience that
students cannot really read even in
college cursive the vast majority
perhaps at least that vast majority is
too much but at least 40 to 50 percent
of the students cannot read cursive and
they're presented when they're presented
with it they they blank out and and then
they panic and therefore I've had to uh
take some time extra time to in fact
show them how it works and when I've
done it like two or three times
it took a number of hours but the
students were very grateful that I spent
the time and then they told me that they
could use it if they learned how to now
write in cursing as opposed to only read
in cursive so there was two processes
number one the reading cursive and then
the second would be writing cursive and
they appreciated the fact that if they
went to the writing of cursive they
would write this as a skill on their
curriculum and when they applied for a
job because in some cases the ability to
write cursive actually makes a
difference for getting a job
so I can tell you that putting that in a
bill and approving the bill moving from
suggested to required could really
facilitate that also for the acquisition
of skills for students and I think I'd
be very grateful to you all if that
happened
thank you very much
uh are you willing to take any questions
sure are there any questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you very much oh
okay yes
thank you you're welcome and thank you
for being here
um in what capacity did you
realized that students weren't unable to
read the course as a teacher okay sure
yeah in college so and did a follow-up
I'm sorry so it did you write like
comments on papers and they couldn't
read them was that sort of yeah and I I
had the students come over for uh during
my office hours and then I taught them
and that I showed them and that I gave
them
um videos to to learn and to essentially
be able to read once they were able to
do that
um two of them out of the three came to
ask for how could they write and of
course I said I'm not gonna be able to
do that but I could tell you that there
was an interest in in them learning how
to write
foreign
thank you I had a similar experience oh
really thank you representative patnell
do you have a question
yes thank you Mr chair
um in your opinion how challenging do
you think these students found it to
learn cursive essentially as adults as
opposed to if they had learned it in
first second third grade like most of us
learned it
um
there was a
a sort of block for maybe an hour but
then you know you just show them
different words and and you help them at
the beginning and then they oh yeah
that's the G that's capital G which
doesn't look like a cursive G
um and they're like oh yeah okay I can
you know they will memorize it and
they'll be happy that they learned it
and it's it's almost instant
gratification on their part once they've
acquired this uh the deciphering of this
strange symbol they're very happy that
they can do it from now on
thank you
further questions
thank you very much you're welcome
Lori ball
is she here
oh okay
hi my name is Lori ball I am a
representative from District 25 which is
in Salem
um I'm here to speak on four
the changing of the word encouraged to
required to give you a little bit of my
background I have been in education in
some capacity for the last 30 years I've
spent
um 12 years teaching Middle School I'm
certified in four areas of Education in
New Hampshire one of which is a reading
and writing specialist with an emphasis
on teaching children with dyslexia
a couple things
um that I just sorry I sound nervous
because I am
a couple of things that I'd like to just
kind of lay a little bit of a groundwork
as a special education teacher we are
taught to always go or think of the
least dangerous assumption if we can
meet the needs of our at-risk students
in the general education classroom then
all students will benefit cursive
writing and multiplication tables is
something that our at-risk students have
difficulty mastering and if we worked on
that in the general education classroom
all students would acquire that skill as
well
a couple of questions that came up that
I would like to address before I forget
or before you forget
um is I'd just like to point out that in
Montessori School
um children are taught to write in
cursive from Two and a Half
and they are taught to read and block
and by doing that the children learn
both
as far as why children would have
difficulty in the benefit of teaching
cursive writing to younger children is
if we observe children writing or
learning block letters they hold their
pencils extremely tight and requires the
child to lift and lower their pencil
multiple times just to write one letter
for instance to write the letter M they
lift and lower four times to write the
letter h a capital h and a capital N it
would be three times so it's a constant
lifting and lower of the pencil the
other thing that comes into play here is
that the students often have visual
difficulties and they do not have good
spacing between their letters so now
they have to bring in their other hand
because now they are lifting and
lowering to write letters to form the
words but they have to bring their other
hand in to put it down to make sure they
have a space between their words
if cursive writing is taught there is it
takes that away we don't we can't write
letters backwards because it doesn't
flow the children are learning to write
from left to right and the words have a
beginning and an end and so that's
another component of Y cursive uh works
for so many young children
you had a question as to where it falls
in the curriculum and cursive would be a
part of literacy it is a part of
communication in both reading and
expressing yourself and you asked about
would curse of adding cursive to an IEP
cause a fiscal impact and absolutely it
would because typically fiscal cursive
writing is not taught by the special
educator but by the OT specialist so
that's another teacher that would have
to be put on the child's IEP
um all that being said I will now go in
my direction
um
and come from the standpoint
of why we identify children from special
education under specific learning
disabilities
um
now that I'm looking at this I've
realized I forgot to thank you for
allowing me to testify I'm sorry
kind of jumped into it and went into my
candidates which I tend to do
um but I do respectfully submit this
following argument
if we recognize that the original Bill
encouraging cursive writing and learning
multiplication table addresses the needs
of students with dyslexia dysgraphia and
dyscalcula which means students who do
not write do not read and do not
calculate at Express at expected levels
and if we understand that students who
perform these who cannot perform these
simple literacy tasks efficiently are
referred to special education to rule
out an educational disability in the
area of special education
and as we further understand that
Federal Law requires the administration
of an academic evaluation to assess
students ability to form these simple
tasks include the student's ability to
formulate and write sentences quickly
including writing sentences as many
sentences as possible within seven
minutes time frame
it also evaluates the student's ability
to perform paper and pencil math calc
computations
it also assesses the student's ability
to solve as many simple addition
subtraction and multiplication facts as
possible within three minutes
and to this I would add
the reason multiplication is in there
and we don't see division is because
students with dyslexia are right brain
students
and right brain takes care of addition
and subtraction left brain handles
multiplication
that is the area of weakness for a
student with dyslexia or dyscalcula so
they have to be explicitly taught to
work on these skills to get fluency if
you don't teach them the multiplication
facts if they don't learn them they will
never because they will rely on repeat
addition so they are way slowed down
um getting back to this if we are aware
that students identified as a student
with an educational disability in the
area of specific learning disabilities
are not developmentally disabled meaning
that students with specific learning
disabilities have IQs above 70 and are
capable of learning and improving these
basic literacy skills Beyond a
functional level
and if we know that students identified
with special with specific learning
disabilities may be removed from the
general education environment in order
to receive specialized instruction
to address these fluency deficits
and if we also understand that according
to the 2021 Statewide sentence census
thirty thousand three hundred and nine
New Hampshire students are identified
with an educational disability and of
those 97
767 are students with specific learning
disability
that's basic literacy skills that we
have nine thousand over nine thousand
students not proficient
and if putting all these facts together
you can see how failing to require the
teaching of cursive writing and
multiplication tables could result in an
over-identified identification of New
Hampshire students with an educational
disability in the area of specific
learning disability when in fact these
students have not been provided the
opportunity to learn and master the
skills being assessed as part of the
special education process as required by
federal law
then you would have to agree that for
the sake of the students who need to
increase these writing and math fluency
skills you must provide
an opportunity to learn and master
cursive writing and multiplication
skills in the general education
classroom so these students are assured
equal access to the curriculum and
receive a free appropriate public
education better known as fape
by amending HB 170 to change the word
from encourage to require thank you
thank you very much Lori I have a
question for you yes as a teacher yes
worked with young people
are you seeing more folks today as I
guess I see two in stores when you the
fine motor skills and holding a pin now
is done in convoluted ways and it
appears to me that kids are struggling
or adults are struggling now and just
getting something written down on a
piece of paper
are you seeing an increase in the number
of students that you work with that just
do not have even the concept of how to
hold a pencil or a pen
I will clarify that I retired in June of
2019 Miss covet but um I and at that
time I would say that yes there is a
hard time of the children holding their
pens and pencils and they do have
difficulty as I said they over grasp and
they hold very their pencils very
tightly
yeah questions of
the speaker
not seeing any
oh I I representative
thank you I'm going to ask the same
question I asked the previous speaker
and that is do you know of specific
instances where these are not being
taught in our schools thank you
thank you for your question yes I do
when left to the discretion of the
teacher teachers can choose to teach it
or not to teach it I have children in
the Salem School District One in third
grade and I have not seen any indication
that he is learning cursive writing
another representative told me that she
has two children in the Windham School
District and these are both very quality
school districts one child was taught
cursive and one was not
um and I should also mention that it is
required that when signing legal
documents children for adults do need to
um sign in cursive printing is not
accepted on legal documents
um
and I will also point out that the
hardest part of being a special
education teacher in the middle school
is sitting with parents of 7th and 8th
graders and identifying their child with
a specific learning disability knowing
they've never been taught the skill
thank you very much for the questions
not seeing thank you very much for your
testing thank you very much if you have
a copy of what you read to us did you
did you get that yeah
okay to have a copy of that I included
um the Woodcock Johnson that is the
standard test other than the um the uh
welchler I I didn't print that off and I
also printed this off of the the census
off of our education department thank
you very much thank you
thank you are there any other folks who
want to testify on on this bill
yes
he says I saw that
good afternoon for the record
um nice to see everyone again Becky
Wilson from the New Hampshire school
boards Association again we would like
to thank the sponsors and the
co-sponsors of this bill for their
passion and bringing forward a topic and
a Content area and the skill that they
feel are so important for students in
New Hampshire we certainly do not
um want to get into whether or not those
skills Etc are of importance however as
we had said earlier on other content
bills and we will not probably testify
on every content specific bill that
comes to this committee however we
currently have two long-standing
resolutions which support local School
Board responsibility for and the
oversight of the local educational
programs this again goes against
allowing local school districts to
determine and to oversee specific
programs as we had stated previously
with some of the other content specific
bills the minimum standards for public
school approval are currently undergoing
a very rigorous extensive process for
revision right now that includes lots of
community opportunity for feedback
feedback from teachers feedback from
students and parents if these particular
skills are not currently required which
we realize the statute currently says
encourage and to many of the points that
have come to this committee this
afternoon it's unclear how many
districts are or are not doing this at
the general classroom level versus at a
student-specific level based on need but
if it is something that rises to the
level of the larger Community feeling
that it needs to be included in the
minimum standards for public school
approval then we would encourage this
committee to give that information to
the groups that are working on the
revisions for the ed306 and the other
committee legislative committee that is
overseeing some of that work
again there are
um to some of the previous points made
many students who do have access to
learning cursive writing and
multiplication tables either within the
context of the General Ed setting or in
some other setting as part of a
student's individualized education
program
and that's where we would suggest that
those that information goes in terms of
trying to incorporate those things into
whether it is a mandatory curriculum
aspect or at the discretion of the local
school board we would also just remind
people that as more skills and content
Etc programs are incorporated into the
minimum standards that that is part of
what is considered an adequate education
in the state and that is to be funded by
by the state in that particular way
whether or not the local district has to
choose a program if it is being mandated
by the legislator and by by rules and
statute then that would fall under
adequate education from the state level
thank you I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much Becky are
there any questions of the school boards
Association
yes representative
thank you thank you very much and I
actually Mr chair I think this is
probably more of a question to you but
it's based on what um what Ms Wilson and
um and Dr frew were had had mentioned uh
in their during their testimony today
that um that you know these sorts of
Provisions may be better placed during
the um during the the revisions to the
Ed 306 but I was wondering Mr chair if
you could speak a little bit to the um
you know the process that may be
available to people to and members of
the public as well as some
representatives for um commenting and
providing feedback on these um the Ed
306 rules
well first of all Ed 306 the minimum
standards for public school approval
are not the academic standards
and they when we look at what are the
targets which we have that we're going
to take in and align our our Improvement
and assessment uh process in the state
with it's going to be the targets that
we established now we put some courses
or some requirements under the area of
studies not necessarily underneath the
adequate education which we feel that
are important for you know our students
to have when they leave the gate in 12th
grade so to get these changes made
there's quite a process here now I I
think this is another area that we
really do need to investigate because
there's a lot of rain a lot of aspects
and and results of of associated with
that for example the teaching of cursive
and a lot of brain research out there on
it now as well and and and and muscle
memory uh so I I in terms of how we
address this one
um in you know I the minimum Public
School standards incorporates a whole
lot of things so how many custodians you
might have in the building it's not just
you know what you learn through your
instruction or curriculum it's you know
oftentimes the the the
um the the whole domain of what we call
public and public education and and it
deals with our competencies as well but
I think we gotta look at those academic
standards too you know our our
assessment which we use as a result of
the national assessment
deals with certain standards which when
adopted in the last standards for
example mathematics came out of the
Common Core which we now call the New
Hampshire standards for a career and and
and college readiness and the same thing
with the language arts area
so we want to look at those standards
which are applicable to those I I'm not
so Keen I always going to the minimum uh
standards of public school approval I'm
looking for those standards which we
want the kids to have when they leave
the school where is the bar going to be
and what do they need to teach
I'm a strong believer that some of the
things we did when I started teaching
Back in 1970 after I came out of where I
was an instructor at Maine Military
Academy
are still valid today
and there are a lot of things we did
back then that we see the pendulum in
education going back and forth we are
great at inventing things in education
you know we look at open classrooms
classrooms Without Walls classrooms with
walls and then we go on to how to teach
science inquiry science and all this
other stuff with the old ESS programs
and all that and now we're into
representative cascad you know what I'm
talking about
and and and so uh this is an area that I
think we as a committee really need to
look at and and and we at the end result
represento is we got to do what's best
for the kids
yeah so I think we're all there on that
that's the kids which we're trying to
get ready for this world so
um
I don't have all the answers
you know I've been around a long time
but uh
I I'm not ready to give the ghost up I
think there's some things which we have
to do and accomplish here in education
and this may be one
thank you you're welcome anything else
for School Board Association
now saying thank you are there any other
folks that want to testify on this bill
170 if not we're going to slam the gavel
down and call it a day
thank you very much
um so tomorrow me we meet again and we
meet first over in reps Hall
across the way tomorrow tomorrow
morning tomorrow morning oh that's
because that's the one yeah in the
morning in the morning we're over there
in the afternoon we have a couple bills
on this side
yeah
get on the web and look at all the new
bills which are coming at us we're
seeing over 30 bills now with fiscal
notes
yeah 9 30. I didn't want to throw this
into the education The Simple Solution
to this is to link it to driver's ed
because they have to assign a legal
document in the script and say you can't
take Driver's edit you can't do Thursday
you know I I watch my Junior High kids
now and they are absolutely laboring to
sign their name now oh yeah and they're
holding their Penance is ridiculous how
they do it right here I think they're
awesome there should be a card for Becky
in here some for 172. I saw one
initially
oh they don't sell it yeah maybe it got
mixed up one of these animals over here
so I'm not going to mess up your stuff
all right
let me give you one make sure you have
one of each
other
that was for 170 also yeah
um
see here's the one for Becky right here
and it's 170 and see this is the 147 pie
okay now did she also do anything here
the reason is because